So I was thinking the other day
about
numbers,
you know,
there are mathematicians who think that there isn't anything more real,
the numbers,
and that's an interesting proposition.
I mean it's obviously the case that once you invent or discover numbers that
that confers on you a tremendous power and who knows the limits of that power
and
the claim that numbers are more real than anything else is predicated in part on
the fact that when you discover them or invent them and start to utilize them,
that your ability to operate in the world expands immensely.
And so that's one of the ways of judging whether or not something is real is
whether or not when you use it,
that facilitates your means of operating in the world.
Interestingly,
numbers are abstractions.
And so that raises another question which is,
well,
what's more real?
The thing that's being abstracted from or the abstractions and again that's not
obvious and maybe the question of more real isn't Germane.
Maybe it's a question of equal reality,
but it's not obvious that abstractions aren't real and you can make a strong
case that there are more real than anything else,
and so then you might ask yourself,
well then what are the most real abstractions?
And so that's what I'm going to start to talk about tonight.
I'm going to talk about it in relationship to as many rules as I can
layout simultaneously.
I'll go through the rules first.
So rule one is stand up straight with your shoulders back,
and rule two is treat yourself like you're someone responsible for helping a
number three,
which is very tightly associated with number two.
There are sort of variations on a theme is make friends with those people who
want the best for you.
And by the way,
these last two rules aren't injunctions designed to make your life easier.
They're actually injunctions designed to make your life more difficult.
Character Guard said at one point that his role in life,
given that everything was proceeding to become easier and easier in all possible
ways,
that there would come a time when people would cry out for difficulty.
And so that's partly how he envisioned role in the world,
interestingly enough,
as a universal benefactor of mankind who would strive to do nothing other than
to make life more difficult for everyone.
Right?
And so rule two and three are like that because treat yourself as if you're
someone responsible for helping isn't the same as be nice to yourself.
It's not that.
And to associate with people who want the best for you means that they get to
demand the best from you.
And that's also not an easy thing.
Rule four is compare yourself to who you were yesterday and not to who someone
else is today.
And that's an injunction about envy,
right?
It's easy.
You need people who need things that are above you because you need to do
something worthwhile with your life.
You need something to a map,
but one of the consequences of that is that you can become envious of people
that you believe have attained more in a deserved or undeserved manner,
and that can make you better.
And so it's much better to compare yourself to yourself and to use yourself as
the target for improvement.
And comparison rule five is don't let your children do anything that makes you
dislike them,
and the rule of thumb there is if you dislike them,
then other people will,
and it's a bad idea to allow your children to act in a way that makes other
children disliked them or adults disliked them,
given that they're going to have to deal with children and they're going to have
to deal with adults.
So your primary responsibility as a parent is to help your child learn how to
behave so that the social world opens up its arms to them and welcomes them at
every level and you've done your job.
If you can manage that,
and it's not a simple thing to do.
Rule six is put your house in perfect order before you criticize the world,
and that's not take no action for others until you have your act together.
That isn't what the rule means.
It means that bind your ambition with humility and work on what's right in front
of you that you will suffer for if you get wrong,
before you engage in the large scale transformation of other people.
Rule seven is do what is meaningful and not what is expedient,
and I would say in some sense in some sense,
that's the core ethos of the book,
not exactly because rule eight,
which is tell the truth or at least don't lie as a necessary conjunction to that
are unnecessary additional element because I don't think that you can pursue
what is meaningful without telling the truth,
and the reason for that is if you don't tell the truth or let's say if you lie,
which is an easier way to think about it,
you corrupt the mechanisms,
the instinctual mechanisms that that that manifest as meaning and then you can't
trust them and that's a very bad idea.
So the fundamental reason to not lie is because you corrupt your own
perceptions.
If you lie and when you corrupt your own perceptions,
then you can't rely on yourself and if you can't rely on yourself,
then well good luck to you because what are you going to rely on in the absence
of your own judgment?
Your you've got nothing.
If you,
if you lose that rule,
rule eight a is,
as I said,
tell the truth or don't,
or at least don't lie.
Rule nine,
assume that the person that you're listening to know something you don't,
and that's not so much a mark of respect for the person,
although it is that it's a mark of recognition of your own unbearable ignorance.
You know,
one of the things you have to do in life is decide whether you're more.
You have to make friends more with.
Let me see.
Let me,
let me rephrase that properly.
You have to decide what's more important,
what you know or what you don't know.
First of all,
there's a lot of what you don't know,
and so if you make friends with that,
if you decide that's important,
then well,
that's a good thing because you're going to be surrounded by what you don't know
your entire life.
And so if you're appreciative of that,
then that's going to make things go better for you.
But,
but the other element of that is,
well,
why should you be appreciative of what you don't know?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you shouldn't if you're life is absolutely perfect in every way you have exactly
what you needed and want.
You've put everything in order around you then what you know is sufficient.
But if you believe that things could still be put right around you in your own
personal life and with regard to the effect that you have,
another people,
then obviously what you don't yet know,
it was more important than what you do know and you should be paying attention
to find out what you don't know at every possible moment.
And if you're fortunate,
when you have a conversation with someone and you're actually interested in what
they say,
then even if they're not very good at communicating,
even if they're awkward or even if they display a certain amount of enmity
towards you,
there's always the possibility that they might tell you something you don't
know.
In which case you can walk away from the conversation less ignorant and corrupt
than you were when you started the conversation.
And if your life isn't everything that you would like it to be,
than being slightly less ignorant and corrupt is probably a good thing,
and so the rule 10 years be precise in your speech and that's that's an
observation I would say that that's a variant of a new testament in junction
which is or maybe a description of the nature of the world which is knock and
the door will open and ask and you will receive which a very strange theory
let's say,
but which I would say is far more in accordance with what we know about the
psychology of perception,
let's say,
than you might imagine because it is the case that
you don't get what you don't aim at.
You might get what you do a mat and your aim might get better as you aim as
well,
which is something to consider
if you specify the nature of the.
Actually.
If you specify the nature of the being that you want to bring into being,
then you radically increased the probability that that's what will occur.
And of course you all know that because you regard yourself at least to some
degree as active creative agents,
right?
Your fundamental attitude towards yourself at at least in the manner that you
act towards yourself is that you wake up in the morning and you have a landscape
of possibilities that lay themselves open to you and you make choices between
those possibilities and determined in consequence how the world is going to
manifest itself.
So you confront a field of potential.
That's a good way of thinking about it and through your choices you determine
which elements of that potential are going to concretize them selves into the
real world and you are very unhappy with yourself.
If you don't do that properly and you're very unhappy with other people.
If they don't do that properly and you're very unhappy with other people.
If they don't treat you like that's what you're like.
Because part of what you demand from people,
let's say in terms of sheer civility is that they act towards you is if you're
the locus of voluntary choice in a world of potential and you are braid each
other for that as well.
If you have children and parents,
your parents will say to you,
if you're fortunate,
you're not living up to your potential,
which is actually a compliment in a sense,
even though it's also a judgment and the compliment is I know perfectly well
that you could be more than you are and you're hang your head if you have any
sense and you'll think like you think in relationship to your own conscience,
that yes,
I have a lot of potential that are not fully realizing and that actually
constitutes a transgression against the good and I don't.
I don't think I've ever met anyone who doesn't believe that.
If you.
If you have a reasonable conversation with them,
it just seems self evident.
I mean,
maybe now and then you meet someone who's narcissistically self satisfied,
but then they're narcissistic and that's not good.
That as a,
as a medium to longterm strategy,
that's a catastrophe that ends in disaster.
You know,
it's a short term.
It protects people,
but longterm it's.
It's not good in the least,
and of course other people don't appreciate it as well.
Rule 11 is don't bother children when they're skateboarding and that's actually
a discussion of courage,
of encouragement more more specifically because I've been trying to understand,
for example,
what role parents play in the lives of their children and I would say this is a
role that that that is a fundamental importance as well as attempting to guide
your children so that they act in a socially desirable manner so that the world
opens itself up to them.
You also want to encourage them,
which is not the same as sheltering them.
It's not the same at all.
And to encourage someone is to say something like or to act out something like,
look,
kid,
as you move,
the world's already difficult because the world isn't easy for children anymore
than it's easy for adults.
The difficulties are they're not the same.
Their child's size difficulties,
but there are still difficulties.
The world is a very hard place and it's a bitter place in many ways and it's not
only a hard and bitter place.
It's also touched with betrayal and malevolence and that's the fundamental
bottom line,
but there's something in you that is capable of taking that full on and
transcending it and that encouragement.
You say,
well,
as difficult as things are,
you're up to the challenge and to interfere with children when they're
skateboarding.
For example,
when they're doing,
let's say in advisably dangerous things which kids of course do.
If they're skateboarding.
To interfere with that is to interfere with the child's willingness to
voluntarily expose themselves to the risks that they need to expose themselves
to in order to develop this sort of competence that allows them to thrive in a
world they cannot be sheltered from.
And so to interfere with children when they're taking the necessary risks is not
love or empathy,
but cowardice on the part of parents and it's deeply damaging to children.
And I can tell you as a clinical psychologist,
I've never had a client come to my office in all the hundreds in,
in,
in all of the hundreds of encounters I've had with people in my office.
I've never had a client say my parents made me to independent.
Right?
That hasn't happened once.
Right now my parents made me too dependent or I conspired with my parents to
perpetuate my dependence.
That happened all the time.
So there's a rule of thumb,
which I think is a good one,
which I believe is often applied in nursing homes by people who work in nursing
homes,
which is of course a very difficult job.
And the rule is do not do anything for anyone they can do for themselves.
And the reason for that is that it's a form of theft,
right?
You don't first all,
if you.
If you do something for someone and it facilitates their movement forward,
then they moved forward because you help them.
Which is something I was very careful about as a therapist.
I don't want to give my clients advice first.
It might fail,
in which case they are going to pay for my advice and second,
if it succeeds,
then I get to be the successful one and I don't want to steal the success from
my clients.
That's a bad idea.
I want to help them figure out what it is that they should aim at and then help
plot out a strategy for attaining that and but I want to ensure that it's their
destiny,
not something I'm imposing,
and of course the imposition of that sort of thing is the hallmark of a bad,
I would say therapeutic relationship,
but also a bad relationship period.
Right?
So one of the things you want to do with your partners,
your spouse or your say your husband or wife and also with your children,
is to listen to them so that you can figure out what their problems are and
figure out with them because they're going to figure that out by communicating
and then perhaps aid them in the development of a strategy,
but you have to ensure very carefully that you're not imposing your own
structure in a manner that's going to steal from them.
What's rightfully theirs,
so,
so rule 11 is an injunction to courage as the fundamental because you could say,
well,
what's the antidote to the catastrophe of life?
And one answer might be safety.
It's like,
well,
you know,
look everyone sensible enough to know that a certain amount of provision for
safety is,
is worthwhile.
You should probably wear your seat belts when you're driving around in your car
because why take fool hardy risks,
but given that there is no security in life,
in the final analysis than encouragement is a much better medication than
sheltering and so,
and that was,
that's,
that's I think in keeping with the idea that what life is essentially is not a
place to attain happiness or even to aim for happiness even though you should be
grateful if someone comes along now and then,
but a call to something like adventure.
And I think that's the proper way of conceptualizing it.
Certainly if you go watch a story,
a movie,
read a book,
something like that.
If you encounter a narrative that's gripping,
whether it's a romance or a classic adventure story,
then the element of it that's gripping is the adventure,
and so to portray life as an adventure in romance and and in the world is the
proper way to portray it and the way that you
facilitate the adventure is through encouragement.
I had a client once.
I really liked him.
He was a good guy,
smart guy,
good looking young guy,
had everything going for him.
You know,
he's a good musician.
He was a talented athlete,
but he hadn't been encouraged.
I wouldn't say
he told me about his relationship with his girlfriend.
He said
his girlfriend wanted to go biking around southern Ontario.
She was about 19 or 20 and he thought he might join her and when she went and
talked to her parents,
they made every provision possible to help her prepare for the journey to make
sure her bike was in good shape,
to make sure she had the right equipment to help her plot out a route,
and when he went and talked to his parents,
all they did was worried that he was going to get hurt and like he might get
hurt because people get hurt,
but they didn't understand that they were choosing between the hurt that he
might encounter by going out in the world and having an adventure,
let's say with his girlfriend or the hurt that he would encounter by staying at
home,
towering in his basement,
under the protection of his over loving parents.
Well,
his girlfriend ventured bravely into the world.
You think,
well,
which of those two things is most likely to be damaging?
And their answer to that is,
well,
his parents wouldn't worry as much as if he.
If he was in the basement and that's the wrong worry.
Even because they should worry more.
Not less so in rural 12,
his pedicab when you encounter one on the street and it's a oddly enough,
a meditation on fragility.
It's a discussion of what you do when you don't know what to do and that's
really when things have gone badly for you.
When you face a terrible tragedy in your own personal life or in your familiar
life or perhaps even in the life of your community.
When things come crowding in and you too quickly in,
in,
in the case of a death in the family or a terrible illness or the collapse of a
dream or any of the things that can flip your world.
Upside down is how do you cope with that.
And that chapter contains discussion of the necessity of narrowing your
timeframe.
Because sometimes the right way to look at the world is across years and
sometimes it's across months and when things are more out of control,
perhaps it's across days and when things are really.
When you're really up against the wall,
it's a car across hours or even minutes and during those minutes then you
concentrate on doing as well as you can.
With what's right in front of you for the longest unit of time that you can
tolerate conceptualizing.
Maybe that's what you do at someone's deathbed and while you're doing that and
suffering away madly,
then you also take the time to appreciate everything you can.
That manifests itself,
that allows itself to be appreciated.
And so that's the metaphor of the cat,
I suppose.
And so that's the 12 rules and I'll return to rule one which is stand up
straight with your shoulders back,
and I'm going to use it as platform for laying out the abstractions that I
talked to at the beginning of the lecture.
So some of you might be familiar with the central Dallas symbol.
It's a symbol of dao and dow is a very strange word.
It doesn't have an easily translatable single meaning,
at least in English.
It means a variety of things.
That means the path of life.
So that would mean that the path that you take as you move forward through life,
but it would mean more also the proper path.
So it's that.
It's the proper path through life.
So the idea dow is a symbol of reality and one of the things that means is the
path you take through life,
and so there's an implicit idea there that the fundamental reality of life is
the path you take through life.
It's not a materialist idea,
it's a different kind of idea.
It's the idea that life is a journey while we're mobile creatures and we're on a
journey and the best way to conceptualize reality is as the place that you
journey through,
and the question is,
well,
what are the elements?
What are the constituent elements of the place that you journey through?
Because that's also part of Dow and the Dallas believed that that's the Yin and
Yang,
and Yin is the black serpent because those are two serpent's head to head that
make up the totality of the world,
and the black serpent is Yin and Yang.
Yin is feminine.
Classically speaking,
from the Taoist perspective,
it's a symbolic representation.
It doesn't mean that women are Yin and that men,
men aren't.
It's not that it's an attempt to use sexual symbolism to represent a deeper
underlying reality,
and Yang is masculine.
Urine is dark and night and there's a white.in the black serpent and there's a
black.in the white serpent.
The serpent is the daytime and masculinity and it's the interplay between those
two things that make up reality and one can transform into the other at any
moment,
and so that's the Taoist idea of reality,
and so there's Yin and Yang and they make up the world and the question is
perhaps act question is,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
Well,
it actually means something.
It's a kind of abstraction and it's actually an incredibly helpful obstruction.
Once you understand the abstraction,
it might be the most real abstraction there is.
So I'm going to lay out a little bit on layout for you,
a little bit about what these two domains refer to,
and then I'm going to make a case that they're real and then I'm going to tell
you what it means that they're real.
So you could think of Yin as chaos.
Now we need to know what chaos is now.
Chaos is what God made the world out of at the beginning of time.
So one of the things that chaos is this,
something like potential and so you can imagine,
and this is not how we think as modern people because we tend to think in a
materialist way,
but it is how we act
and as I said already,
you act as if you confront potential and you treat potential as if it's real and
if your attitude towards it confers on you a certain moral obligation,
which is why you know what people mean when they say you're not living up to
your potential.
No one ever says,
well what do you mean by potential?
Not unless they're being argumentative,
because you already know and very few people say,
while I'm fully living up to my potential.
So you admit to the reality that undergirds that conception that makes that
question and possibility immediately.
The potential is while potential is the future.
That's part of it and we believe in the future.
We believe that it exists.
Even though it isn't here and it's not measurable.
It's.
It only exists as a potential set of realizable possibilities.
That's what the future is and it's really what we contend with.
We don't really contend with the present precisely.
We Orient Ourselves towards the future and the future comes at us from every
direction and we we,
we decide as we encounter the future,
which parts of it we're going to interact with and how we're going to construct
the present and the past as a consequence of doing that,
and so part of chaos is potential and that's the positive part.
It's like if you're in a bind,
what you look for is potential.
Is there another way of conceptualizing this?
Do I have a different way of of acting?
Can I make another plan?
Is there something that I'm not taking into account that would make this
terrible situation tolerable?
That's all an attempt to to call upon potential and to use it to transfigure a
reality that's intolerable and maybe it's intolerable because of the way you're
conceptualizing it.
Now.
I'm not being naive about that.
I understand perfectly well that people can find themselves so badly cornered in
life that they're basically done no matter what they do.
People obviously developed fatal illnesses and they die and their businesses
collapsed and genuinely terrible things can happen to you that aren't your
fault,
that you can't fix.
I'm not saying that you can just gerrymander the world by changing your
attitude.
It's not that straightforward,
but I am saying that you have a tremendous ability to transform the landscape of
possibility that reveals itself in front of you and that when things are
terrible,
that's your best bet.
It doesn't mean it will succeed.
It just means you don't have a better option and so chaos.
That potential is also something that manifests itself in a terrible manner.
So imagine this.
This is a good way of thinking about it.
So imagine that you have an intimate relationship.
Let's say a marriage and the marriage is predicated on trust and fidelity,
which is a variant of trust,
and that trust and fidelity is an axiom of your memories.
You might think,
well,
what does that mean?
It's like,
well,
let's play it out.
Imagine you've been married for 10 years and then your wife tells you that she
has had three affairs.
Each of them lasted three years and the last one has lasted five years and it's
still ongoing.
Or maybe you discover that,
okay,
so then you might say,
well,
what happens then?
Well,
what happens is that everything you thought was wrong.
Right,
and this is such an interesting thing because it actually means you had the past
and you think the past is fixed.
It's done with.
That's why it's the past,
but all of a sudden you find out that one of the things that you thought about
the past and it happens to be a very important thing wasn't true at all.
And so what that means is that whole past that you thought was what it was,
wasn't what it was at all.
And so it transforms itself from an actuality into potential and most of that
potential is negative.
Unless you're relieved that your wife had an affair.
Well,
but that's an important consideration because you know you can imagine a
situation where your marriage is dreadfully unhappy and you're just looking for
an excuse to leave.
It's possible that that revelation,
even though it would be shocking,
would also come with a fair bit of relief,
and so this potential,
the potential that manifests itself even when it's unexpected,
it doesn't only necessarily manifest itself in a negative guys,
it can also free,
you know,
and and if your marriage was unhappy,
even if you wanted to cling to it,
if your marriage wasn't happy and the betrayal was revealed and you're divorced
and you set yourself up in two years,
you might be in a better place than you were.
It's not a pathway I'm recommending by the way.
I'm just saying that it's more complicated than it looks.
That's the introduction of chaos into order.
Right?
And the the,
the oldest story we have is something like order is susceptible to disruption by
chaos and the human.
That the fundamental demand that's made on the human being is to contend with
the chaos that disrupts order.
Not to live in order and not to live in chaos,
but to be able to contend with the chaos that disrupts order.
And so when you encourage your children,
for example,
what you're doing is encouraging them to become the masters of the chaos that
can disrupt order rather than denizens of order,
which makes them tyrants or Denisons of chaos,
which makes them nihilistic and hopeless.
So you train your children,
you encourage your children and yourself and your partner if you have any sense
to be a master of emergent chaos and to be able to contend with that.
And so,
so chaos has potential and it's this disruptive.
It's the capacity of the infinite world to disrupt your finite considerations.
That's another way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it is it's the serpent in the garden of Eden and the
reason that that story is set up the way it is is because it's trying to
represent that there is no place that so bounded and secure,
even if it's set up by God himself that doesn't have an agent of chaos inside
it.
It's exactly the same idea that the Dallas put forward with their,
with their symbolic representation.
It's just portrayed in a different manner.
The question is,
well,
what do you do in the garden given that there's a snake in it and the answer to
that is something like you become the master of snakes and so and that's a deep
idea.
That's the same idea as confronting the dragon and getting the treasure.
That's the same idea as going to the bottom of the ocean and rescuing your
father from the belly of the whale.
It's the same idea and that's an element in the greatest of stories in the
greatest of stories is heroic,
heroic story and the heroic story is to voluntarily confront the unknown when it
manifests itself and together something of value as a consequence and to share
it with the community.
There isn't a story that's more emblematic of what it means to be human then
that,
that that is us.
That's our best bet.
All right,
so chaos.
Chaos is the catastrophe that will suddenly enter your life.
Chaos is the flood.
That's definitely coming.
Chaos is the ever present possibility of apocalypse in your personal life and
your familiar life and in this broader social life,
right?
Chaos is the consequence of your finite fragility existing in a world that's
beyond you.
Chaos is potential.
Chaos is what lies before you.
Chaos is what you can call on when you need something to rescue yourself from
malfunctioning order.
It's a permanent element of existence.
Chaos is what you don't know.
Chaos is what's outside the fire.
Chaos is what's outside the walls of your house.
Chaos is what's outside the walls of your town.
Chaos is what's outside of the borders of your country.
All of that is chaos and potential
order
order is where you are when what you're doing is working in the manner that you
intended,
okay?
It's a very specific definition.
How do you know that you know what you're doing?
Well,
you don't because you don't know what you're doing because you don't know
everything.
Everything you do is bounded by ignorance while you still have to operate in the
world,
and so what you do is you make finite plans and the new execute plans and then
you execute strategies to to make those plans manifest themselves,
and if the plan's manifest themselves the way that you desired,
then you regard your knowledge as sufficient.
That's your definition of truth and it's the only definition of truth that you
can use because you don't have everything at hand and when you're aware what
you're doing is working that's order and you might think,
well,
I should just stay there because that's a comfortable place to be and there's a
certain amount of truth to that except for one thing.
If you've
defined a domain of order and you stand in it and you wait,
the disorder will enter all by itself because things aren't static.
Things change all the time and your attempt to bind yourself within a static
structure is destined to fail because everything around you is in flux and the
thing that you parceled out as permanent will transform itself across time.
Here's an example.
Let's say you're a perfectly well adapted 11 year old and it's actually possible
to meet 11 year old children are often very delightful because they're like
adult children,
they're not teenagers.
They're like they're.
They're the most mature form of children and they can be really delightful
people and then like three years later you hate them and and the reason for that
is that of course,
as soon as they hit puberty,
which is the emergence of chaos into the,
into the already developed childhood structures,
really the emergence of sexuality into a structure that didn't have to adapt to
sexuality and maybe even the emergence of aggression to some degree,
but mostly sexuality.
If the child maintains only the 11 year old personality by the time they're 16,
they're no longer a delightful 11 year old.
There are very immature 16 year old and the reason that I'm pointing that out is
because just because something works for you now doesn't mean it's going to work
for you five years from now and so in order to remain stable,
you can't be stagnant.
They're not the same thing.
Stability is a dynamic,
not a not something static,
and so not only do you have to be where you are,
but you have to be going to where you're going and you have to be participating
in both of those things actively,
so it's stability plus transformation and I would say that manifests itself.
You know when you're there because that manifests itself as meaningful.
That's actually the instinct of meaning,
which is an instinct and perhaps the deepest instinct is precisely the instinct
that tells you when were you are a sufficiently stable,
but you're transforming yourself at a sufficient rate to keep up with everything
that's changing and you know that because if you're at your job,
you might say to yourself,
well,
my job is really secure,
but it's not very challenging and you think,
well,
why do you care about that?
It's very secure and the answer to that is,
well,
if it's not challenging,
it's deadening in a sense,
right?
The spirit goes out of it.
If it's not challenging,
you need to be challenged and why is that?
Well,
the answer is,
well,
tomorrow is coming and whoever you are now isn't enough for tomorrow and so
today you also have to be preparing for tomorrow and next week and next year,
and if your job isn't challenging than it isn't doing that for you and you find
it deadening,
not meaningful,
and the reason for that is that it violates your most essential instinct and
your most essential instinct is the instinct for meaning and it signifies that.
It actually signifies that you have the balance between chaos and order right
deeply,
right?
Which is why it's the most fundamental of instincts because chaos in order are
the most real of things.
All right,
so you have the chaos that surrounds you and in some some sense infinite in
scope,
and then you have the order that you produce,
which is your mastery of it.
Well,
let's take order apart for a minute.
We want to think about the structure of order and bill,
and I'm not saying that chaos is bad in order as good.
I'm not saying that at all.
That's not the right way to look at it.
It's the balance.
It's the balance between them that's of crucial importance.
They just take.
They exist as superordinate categories.
Whether you liked them or not is really not that relevant.
They're they're,
they're fundamental constituent elements of reality.
You might say,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
And I can tell you one piece of evidence which I won't go into for for very much
time.
You have two hemispheres and each in your brain,
the brain is composed of two hemispheres,
which implies something about the nature of the world,
given that your brain is hypothetically adapted to the structure of the world.
It's not just your brain because animal brains have the same fundamental
structure,
this bifurcated structure and the bifurcation indicates that there's two
fundamental realities because otherwise why would you need a bifurcated
structure or maybe you needed triune brain or one that's divided into four,
but that isn't what you have.
You have one that's divided into two and if your working definition of reality
is scientific,
biological,
let's say,
then your definition of reality is reality is that which shapes life.
You can't actually do better than that from a Darwinian perspective,
and if the reality that shaped life produced a bifurcated representational
structure,
then that implies that the proper way to represent reality and perhaps that
reality itself is in fact bifurcated and I believe it's bifurcated in the manner
I just described and the neurological evidence for that is actually quite
overwhelming.
It's come from multiple sources,
some of them Russian,
some of them American.
That's where most of the work has been done.
Your left hemisphere is specialized for operation in those situations that you
know and understand,
and your right hemisphere is specialized for operation in those situations that
you neither know nor understand,
and the proper way to orient yourself in life is to get the balance between
those two sets of operations correct,
and the way that manifests itself in your subjective experiences as meaningful
engagement.
And so that's not a bad first pass.
What would you say?
Justification for the view that these two domains are the most real domains.
Okay,
so order.
What is order?
Well,
if you just sit there and do nothing,
that will be chaos.
Why?
Well,
because you'll.
You'll suffer and die.
That's what will happen.
So without action on your part.
Deterioration in death is a certainty.
Okay,
so you need to act.
While when we built on an action platform been where the consequence of
3 billion years of evolution for action,
action,
movement forward in the face of necessity is the prime dictum of life.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
Were embodied action.
What do you have to do when you act?
Well,
at minimum,
you have to do whatever keeps you able to act.
These are truisms,
right?
I mean,
you have to have something to eat.
You have to have some fresh water.
You need some shelter,
right?
You need some companionship.
You need a sexual partner,
you need children,
you need play.
You need to be touched,
and I mean,
I actually mean need by the way.
People deprived to play go insane.
People who aren't touched,
die.
These things are necessary.
Well,
assuming that survival itself is necessary,
but we'll start with that.
We'll start with the assumption that just sitting there and suffering and dying
is not the right solution.
Okay?
So you have to act in the world,
you have to act in the world that in a manner that stops you from deteriorating
and dying at minimum,
and that means that you have to address the problems that are intrinsic to that
destiny.
Now you have all sorts of systems that evolved,
have evolved to help you do that.
Motivational systems we have to eat so you get hungry.
You have to find water in and consume it.
So you get thirsty,
you get lonely,
you get curious.
There's there's,
there's specialized biological systems that are very,
very old.
You get aggressive,
you get afraid,
you,
you suffer pain,
all those specialized systems for all of those unit directional systems of
orientation in the and they help you figure out what to do.
So when you're hungry,
it's time to eat and when you're thirsty it's,
it's time to drink.
And when your lonesome,
it's time to seek out some companionship.
And you have specialized systems that help you do that,
but they're not enough because,
well,
they're not very bright.
That's one way of looking at it.
They're kind of uni dimensional and you also have the problem of organizing all
of them.
It's like,
well,
you have to eat now and you have to drink now and you need a companion.
It's probably time to play and you have to do something about shelter and there
isn't just you right now.
There's you now and tomorrow and next week and a year from now,
five years from now,
so you have to plan across all those stretches of time and there isn't just you
now in the future,
you there's you plus your family and your community and so all of that has to be
taken into account while you're plotting.
Your movement forward is very,
very complicated.
You have all these problems to solve simultaneously and your motivational
systems,
anger,
hunger and so forth can help you solve one of those problems now,
but not all of them permanently.
That requires higher cognitive function and that's part of what drove the
evolution of our complex cognitive systems.
That's how do you propagate the game across time in a complex environment.
The left hemisphere operates when,
where,
when,
what you're doing works and so a lot of what you do during your life is to keep
your right hemisphere off.
People don't like it going on accidentally.
It's the home of negative emotion.
It's the home of pain and anxiety.
It's the thing that turns on and freezes you in your tracks when something that
you deeply did not expect happens and it prepares you to deal with the onslaught
of what you didn't expect.
Now it's not all bad news because to use the right hemisphere in a judicious
manner is also something that adds intrigue and interest in artistic expression
and all sorts of positive things to your life.
So because potential is not only negative,
it's also positive.
It can be,
it can be dealt with in ways that are deeply enriching and meaningful order.
Okay,
so you have to do something.
Otherwise the consequences are dire.
To do something,
you have to value something.
It's a definitional issue because to do something is to act out the proposition
that the thing you're doing,
the thing you're aiming at,
let's say is preferable to the thing you have and preferable means you'll do it
so those things are tied together so tightly.
You can't disentangle them.
If you say,
I'm aiming at x,
but I don't value it,
then there's something wrong with the way that you're conceptualizing the
statement because to aim at something and to work to bring it into existence is
the same as valuing it,
and if you say,
well,
I don't value it,
then something's out of kilter.
Either you're acting out a false hood or you don't know what you're talking
about.
It's one of those two things and you meet people like that are deeply confused
there.
Their action patterns and their verbal self representation don't Mesh,
but that doesn't mean that they're critics of value.
It just means that they're deeply confused,
so you have to act or you suffer.
In order to act,
you have to have a value structure because to act you have to value one thing
more than another,
which means that you have to inhabit a structure of value.
You have to,
okay,
so you need a structure value because it's the antidote to catastrophe.
Now,
if you act out a structure of values socially,
which you will because you're social,
you're not going to pursue your aims in isolation because you're not.
You're not a solitary animal.
You're a social animal,
you're a tribal animal,
deeply tribal.
We live in groups.
We live in families,
we live in communities.
We live in large societies were social at every level of analysis and we've been
social for as long as we've been primates,
so maybe that's,
that's at least 6 million years and it might be more like $60,
million years.
It's really a long time,
so it's not an arbitrary social construction.
It's far,
far deeper than that.
Now what happens when you act out a structure of value in this social
environment,
you produce a hierarchy inevitably.
Well,
let's think it through.
Why?
Well,
let's say that you say that one thing is more worth doing than another,
whatever it happens to me,
and then you tell a bunch of people about what you're doing and they decided
that they're going to come along and help you do this thing that's valuable
because they also think it's valuable and maybe you get 20 people together to do
this thing.
Whatever it happens to me and the first thing you discover is that some of the
people are way better at doing whatever it is that they're doing than other
people.
So and that and who knows why that is because it depends on what you chose to
do.
You know?
If you chose a then it would be a different group of people who were good at it.
Then if you chose B,
because people differ in their abilities,
but one thing you will not escape from if you make an organization to do
something valuable is the brute fact that it will be a minority of the people
who are good at doing it.
And there's actually a law.
It's called price's law and it's a real law.
Even governs the size of cities and the massive stars and the heights of plants
in the jungle.
It just doesn't govern human interactions.
And price's law says that the square root of the number of people engaged in an
enterprise,
we'll do half the work.
So if you have 10 people doing something,
three of them will do half the work,
but if you have 100 people doing something,
then 10 of them will do half the work.
And if you have 10,000 people doing something than 100 of them will do half the
work.
And uh,
you know how wealth distributes itself such that a minority of people have most
of the money.
Twelve 85 richest people in the world have as much money as the bottom two and a
half billion.
It's something like that.
And everybody goes,
oh my God,
the one percent.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
you're all the one percent.
So get over yourself because you're know western European,
roughly speaking and by world current world standards.
And certainly by historical standards,
you're all well ensconced in the one percent.
So if that's a problem,
well it's a problem for all of you and some of you might be,
you know,
richer than that,
but that doesn't mean all of you aren't in the same boat.
Fundamentally,
the fact that wealth aggregates in the hands of a small number of people is part
of the general expression of price's law.
There's nothing special about the distribution of money.
You see the same thing in every creative domain mean how many of you have have
recorded a
gold record?
How many looks like zero up?
There's one,
one person,
okay,
there's 850 people in here.
So there's one in the thousands.
So that's one 10th of one percent,
something like that.
How many of you have written a piano concerto?
Uh,
how bout painted a painting that's hanging in a national museum?
Oh look,
it's none of view again,
right?
Well,
and how many of you have been a member of a professional sports team?
Okay,
look up one one.
So that's one in 10,000.
Well,
you get the point here.
if there was a couple,
there is.
Okay.
So looks like it's easier to be a member of a professional sports team
or my or my audience is is biased the samples biased,
but,
but it is the case.
If you look at high levels of creative achievement of the sort of just described
that they characterize it staggering minority of people.
And so the rule is is that you produce a value system which you better produce
because otherwise you suffer and die and it isn't only that,
only that.
It's like,
look,
here's something else you all know as far as I can tell,
we start with the idea that there's an intrinsic chaotic element to life and
that includes the inevitability of suffering and malevolence betrayal at the
hands of yourself and other people.
So that's the baseline.
And that's intolerable in many ways because life is in many ways intolerable.
And the question is,
well,
what do you do in the face of something that's intolerable?
And the answer is when you try to find something that justifies it,
right?
You want to have something that gets you the hell out of bed in the morning and
not just any old morning but a morning when your father has Alzheimer's disease
and your daughter has an incurable illness because you need something to get out
of bed for in those mornings too,
and that better be the that you found in life and if the purpose is going to be
such that it gets you out of bed in those mornings,
it better be a pretty damn noble purpose because otherwise why would you bother?
And so not only do you need a value structure,
you need one that's of sufficient tension,
let's say,
or sufficient value or sufficient nobility so that it's worth suffering for
because you're going to suffer and you better have something that makes the
suffering justifiable.
And so not only do you need the value structure so that you don't just
deteriorate and die.
You need the value structure so that when the flood comes in your life as it
certainly will,
that you have built a vessel that will sustain you through the catastrophe.
And that's not this pursuit of happiness.
It's not even the pursuit of security,
it's none of that.
It's the orientation that you've managed to produce in your own life towards a
higher good that's so high that it's worth bearing the burden of being to
produce.
You implement that in the world.
You produce a hierarchy.
Now you might say,
well,
and then you have the problem of hierarchy and the problem of hierarchy is a
very few people are going to be very good at whatever that hierarchy does and
then you have the second problem with hierarchy,
which is the problem I just laid out when I asked you about your spectacular
levels of attainment and found out that they were very.
It was very unlikely.
I'm not saying that you haven't attained worthwhile things.
That's not my point.
My point is is that very high levels of attainment or extraordinarily rare and
that's an inevitability.
As soon as you decide that something's worth doing to inevitabilities,
people stack up at the top minority of people stack up at the top and take most
of the proceeds,
whatever they happen to be or deserve them or earn them,
whatever.
However,
I don't care how you conceptualize it and almost everybody else stacks up at the
bottom,
and so the problem with hierarchies is that even though they're necessary,
they tend to produce a situation where most people stack up at the bottom,
and so that's the next thing that we have to contend with.
You can't get rid of the hierarchies because if you get rid of the hierarchies,
there's no value structure and if there's no value structure,
not only do you deteriorate and die,
you want to deteriorate and die and that's not a good solution.
But if you do generate a hierarchy,
then you have the problem of the hierarchy.
And the problem is the hierarchy is that it will dispossess most people now,
to the degree that the postmodernists have something to say,
that's what they say is hierarchies,
dispossessed,
okay.
And then we can look at that clearly and carefully and we can say that doesn't
mean a,
that hierarchies themselves are corrupt or that we can dispense with them,
but it also doesn't mean that we have no moral obligation to the dispossessed.
And we say,
well,
how do we deal with that politically,
conceptually and the way we deal with that,
at least in part,
is to produce a political spectrum that ranges from left to right that deals
with hierarchy and the problems that hierarchies caused.
So one of the things that you can reliably assume about someone who's on the
right is that they will be patriotically in favor of the current hierarchy or
even more abstractly,
they're in favor of the idea of hierarchy itself and you say,
well,
more power to the people on the right because you need hierarchies so they
should support them.
But then you have to take the people on the left who say,
yeah,
but what about the people who are dispossessed by the hierarchy?
And what you have to say to them is,
yeah,
we actually have to do something about that.
And you think,
well how do we do something about that?
And the answer is we don't actually know because there's no permanent solution
to the problem of dispossession by the hierarchy.
We don't know how to fix it.
Say,
well,
we could flatten hierarchies.
It's like not without disrupting the value structure.
That's a price you don't want to pay.
Well,
we can take from the top and put it at the bottom.
It's like,
yes,
hypothetically we could,
but it turns out that when you try that in practice,
it's very,
very easy to rapidly go too far and then what you end up with not is less
dispossessed.
You end up with no one who has anything and that's not a good solution to the
problem of scarcity,
right?
To make everyone equally dead or equally starving,
which is essentially what the communist states did across the entirety of the
20th century is not the proper way to address the problem of hierarchy.
Now it has to be addressed even if you're on the right,
because here's one thing that happens.
Hierarchies tend to Ossify,
you know,
because what happens is that the people at the top,
maybe they got there by merit,
but it's easy for them to Gerrymander the system so they can stay there without
merit.
Or perhaps their children can stay there without merit or they can.
Or the hierarchy becomes corrupt so that people who only use tyranny and power
can climate,
and so you don't have a hierarchy of competence and value anymore.
You have a hierarchy of brute power which looks like a tyranny,
so there's all sorts of ways that hierarchies can deteriorate and we have to be
awake to ensure that that doesn't occur.
Also,
if the hierarchy gets so steep that everybody stacks up at zero and no one can
climb it,
which is basically the definition of a malfunctioning tyranny than all the
people at the bottom rightly think,
well,
why don't we just destroy the game because we're already at zero?
So what the hell do we have to lose?
And so one of the things that you want to do if you're a sensible conservative,
is make sure that the hierarchy maintains its routing and competence,
that it's transparent and that it's climate double because otherwise it will
ossify in steepen and then it will destroy itself.
And if you're a conservative and you value stability and the hierarchy,
then you don't want to set up a situation where the most likely outcome is that
the hierarchy destroys itself.
So so we can be intelligent about this.
We could say,
look,
don't be thinking.
You can get rid of hierarchies they've been around.
This is why I wrote chapter one.
I talked about lobsters.
The reason I talked about them is because not only is the hierarchical structure
itself as a permanent feature of existence,
at least a third of a billion years old,
which by the way means that you cannot attribute it to capitalism,
the free market or the corrupt patriarchal west,
unless you're willing to make the case that all three of those elements
contributed to the existence of dominance hierarchies among crustaceans,
which seems highly unlikely.
So,
and this is actually something that's,
that you can think about it as an idea that's actually directed towards the
productive left.
If you want to help the dispossessed,
don't blame the existence of hierarchies on capitalism because it's wrong.
It's wrong that the problem is way deeper than that.
And here's something else that's very interesting about capitalism,
couple of things you might consider,
you know,
we have become spectacularly wealthy since 18,
95,
right?
First in the West Icelands at classic example.
I mean you guys are so much more wealthy than you were a hundred years ago that
it's absolutely impossible to believe.
And so that's first happened in the west to exponential economic growth starting
in about 1895.
There's a long tail.
I mean,
people were improving before that,
but it really kicked in around 18,
95 and first happened in the west and now it's happening everywhere in the
world.
I don't know if you know this,
but you know,
the UN set a goal in 2000 to have the level of absolute poverty in the world by
2015,
which is the fastest rate of economic growth ever recorded.
We attained it in 2012,
three years ahead of the most optimistic projections.
Right?
And so people are being lifted out of poverty at a rate that has never been seen
in the history of the world hooked to the power grids provided with cell phones
provided with free,
with access to fresh water provided with access to medications that decrease
child mortality.
Like if you look at the statistics,
there are so many things getting better so fast you cannot even believe it.
And that's,
and here's the consequences as far as as far as the data indicate of the
operation of the free market system,
which does produce inequality.
That's the thing,
but as far as I can tell,
the only system that has ever produced wealth and as law or has every system
produces inequality,
but the only system we know of that produces,
produces wealth and inequality is the free market.
So here's a question for everyone left and right.
How many units of inequality will you tolerate to produce one unit of wealth?
And if the answer is zero,
then you've gone too far.
You're outside the appropriate political debate.
That's the wrong answer.
And if you try to impose that all there will be as mayhem because the price we
pay for wealth is inequality.
Now that doesn't mean that you can let inequality run to its ultimate extreme
because then you run into the other problem,
which is the monopoly problem.
You've all played monopoly.
I presume what happens in every monopoly game,
if you lay it out,
everyone stacks out at zero up at zero except one person.
Now,
if you play it 50 times,
you'll find that it's hardly ever the same person because it's basically a game
of chance and there's a fair bit of chance by the way,
operating in the distribution of money in the world.
It's not all chance,
but there's a fair bit of chance.
But the logical conclusion to a hierarchy that can play itself out totally is
that one person has everything and everyone else has nothing.
Obviously that's not a useful outcome.
So,
so you know,
in the way there are ways that we fix that in our society.
We have progressive tax policies and you can argue about their utility,
but that's one way of rectifying it potentially.
Another way of rectifying is that we don't have one game,
right in a pluralistic society,
we have many,
many games that people can play and so if you can't be a successful lawyer,
then maybe you could be a successful plumber and if you can't be a successful
plumber,
maybe you can run this small restaurant or you know,
there's a diversity of games.
And so that's a good way of,
of allowing,
of increasing the robustness of the system so that you don't get hierarchies
that are so steep that they collapsed in upon themselves.
And so those are sophisticated approaches and perhaps your other approaches to.
But it's an intractable problem.
It says in the New Testament,
it's one of the things you'd swear would be edited out because it's such a harsh
statement.
Uh,
the poor will be with us always.
Well,
what's that in reference to?
It's also in reference to the matthew principle,
which is another new testament statement and happens to be an economic axiom to
those who have everything more will be given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's the structure of the world and you can't lay it at the feet of the West.
It's the structure of the world.
Now that means we have to contend with it and it's not an easy thing to contend
with and part of the reason that we have a continual political dialogue and that
we need to have a continual political dialogue is to make sure that our
hierarchies exist and remain intact,
but don't become so steep and corrupt that they destroy themselves and you need
a left and a right for that,
and if that means the left half has to admit that hierarchies are not only
necessary but valuable and the right has to admit that despite their necessity
and value,
they tend to stack people up at the bottom and that actually constitutes a
continual problem.
You see that in.
You see that in the old testament because one of the things that happens in the
old testament is Israel struggles up to state and empire status.
Six Times.
It struggles out of the chaos,
up to empire status,
and then it gets corrupt.
It loses the way.
It isn't balancing things between chaos and order properly.
The kings get arrogant is so to the people and they forget their relationship
with God.
That's another way of thinking about it,
and then a profit comes up and says,
you aren't paying enough attention to the widows and the orphans.
You better look out because that displeases God and the Israelites who are stiff
necked and arrogant think what's God going to do to us,
which is not a very wise way of thinking and so they don't take the steps
necessary to rectify their deviation from the proper path and they get
absolutely flattened and the consequences of that last for generations like
seven generations,
and then they struggle their way up to something approximating empire status
again and exactly the same thing happens.
They forget and they collapse and there's six stories like that in the Old
Testament.
It's all documented by a man named Northrop Frye who is a Canadian literary
critic who wrote a couple of books on the Bible.
One called the great code and the other called words with power,
which I would highly recommend.
It's an analysis of the Bible as literature.
Brilliant for those of you who might be interested in union thinking,
fries thinking is a nice adjunct,
so alright,
so,
so that's the nature of the world.
Order chaos and order,
and your goal is to keep those,
the relationship between those two things optimized and you do that by doing
what's meaningful,
not what's expedient.
That's rule six and you ensure that you have the world construed properly by
following rule number eight,
which is tell the truth or at least don't lie.
You don't want a path.
All the guys,
the instinct that orients you in the world and you will pathologize it by
engaging in habitual deceit,
and the reason you do that is when you practice something,
you build structures that specialize in that and then they run automatically.
So if you're living a lie,
which is a very common thing for people to do,
then you're building neurological mechanisms that view the world through that
lie and once they're built,
they're you and good luck unbuilding them.
It's very,
very difficult.
That's in part what happens to people who are addicted by the way they build
mechanisms of search,
neurological structures that are focused on the drug and those systems are alive
and all they want is the drug and they're,
they're not.
It's not psychological.
Exactly.
It's psychophysiological.
Don't build structures of cognition predicated on deception because you will pay
for it.
And so if you're going to guide your life with the orientation of the instinct
of meaning,
then you have to be very careful with what you say and write and think because
every time you say or write or think something,
you build a little neurological structure that specialized for that and it
participates in this parsing of the world.
So all right,
chaos and order.
Then you can say the order orders a hierarchy.
Okay,
so here's the next question.
Next two questions is order a hierarchy
and then a subsidiary question would be,
if order is a hierarchy,
what's what?
Either what is at the top of the hierarchy or what should be at the top of the
hierarchy.
The hierarchy is a structure value.
So that's the question is what should be of ultimate value.
Okay.
So now we're going to take that apart a little bit.
The first thing I would say,
his order is not a hierarchy.
Order is a set of hierarchies.
That's a different thing.
So
I'll tell you how to think about that.
I think.
So imagine you have a child and they're playing soccer and uh,
your child is a pretty good soccer player.
No,
I'll tell you a different story.
This actually happened.
So I'm going to tell you a story about hockey and I'm since I'm Canadian.
What the hell?
I might as well tell you a story about hockey.
Um,
my son played hockey.
He still plays hockey.
He's a pretty good hockey player and my wife and I used to go watch him play
hockey.
There was an arena just down the street from us and there was a nice
neighborhood league there.
And so they'd start the kids into teams and then they let them play a few demo
games and if any team was getting stomped flat or any other team was winning too
much,
then they'd rebalance the teams.
So that they were approximately equal in skill.
So that was the sorting of the teams.
So,
um,
and then they,
then they were on their teams and then they'd play 15 games during the regular
season.
They didn't have a little tournament,
see who won and it was really good.
It was good friendly league.
And so my son's team was in,
I think it was the championship game,
if I remember correctly.
And uh,
there's one kid on his team who is the best player on the team by quite a
margin,
you know,
he was very fast on his feet.
He could,
he could skate rings around a lot of the kids.
He was good at stick handling.
He was a good hockey player.
But um,
he had some problems.
This kid,
one problem was he wouldn't pass the puck.
Now you think,
well,
why the hell should you pass the park if you're the best hockey player?
Which is pretty much what he thought.
And the answer is,
well,
you're part of a team,
right?
You want to be the best person on the team,
fair enough and you want to win the hockey game.
But you also want to what make your team mates better players.
How's that?
Maybe you even want to meet the people on other teams,
better players I knew,
now I know that's going a little bit too far,
but you certainly want to make your teammates better players and you might
think,
well why would you do that?
Because if there are better than maybe you won't be the best while that's a bone
headed way of looking at the world because first of all,
if you amp up the competition around you,
maybe that'll motivate you to be even better and it's a hell of a way to win by
making everyone else lose.
That's not much of a victory.
And so if you have any sense,
you pass the damn park.
Even if you're the better player,
especially you especially do that.
Let's say you've got a comfortable two goal lead,
well then maybe you can risk taking the time away from that specific game to
build up the confidence,
confidence and ability of your teammates.
And then maybe everybody thinks that you're a bit of a leader and they make you
team captain.
Not even so much because you're the best hockey player,
but because.
Well,
because why?
That's the question.
Okay.
So we're watching the game and it's pretty exciting and it's real close game and
it's like three to three and it's a minute left and now their team zips down the
nice and scores and really brilliant goal.
And so my son's team loses except that they were in the championship and it was
a really good game.
So you know whether or not they lost is not all that obvious.
They lost that game,
but you know,
there's a broader context to take into consideration.
Okay.
So this kid,
the star goes off the ice and he takes his hockey stick and he smashes it onto
the cement and he's all angry because as far as he was concerned,
he was robbed.
And maybe that's because of his useless teammates who he didn't really spend any
time helping by the way.
And maybe it's because the referees were unfair and who the hell knows why but
it wasn't fair and his idiot farther rushes over to him and consoles him in on
his loss and supports them in his notion that he was robbed and I thought you
unspeakable son of a bitch
because he was an arrogant narcissist and it was way more important to him that
he had a son who was a star then that he had a son who is a good person
and that's absolutely inexcusable.
He made the wrong choice.
He sacrificed his son Soul in part to help them save face for a hockey game.
That's not acceptable.
Okay?
So here's what you tell your children.
It doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
And so that's what the father should have told the son and he should have meant
it.
And even better,
he should have known what it meant.
But who knows what that means because you tell your children that and maybe
they're not so happy because they lost a game and they look at you like you're
an alien.
And they think,
well,
what the hell do you mean by that?
Because obviously it matters whether you win and it does matter whether you win.
So what is it that you mean when you say that?
And your kid asks,
well,
what do you mean by that?
And you go,
well,
I don't know what it means,
but it's a good rule.
So what do you mean by that?
Here's what you mean.
And it relates to rule five,
which is don't make your.
Don't let your children do anything that makes you dislike them because other
people will dislike them.
That and you don't want other people to dislike your children unless you want
your children to inhabit a world where everyone dislikes them.
And maybe you do because you don't like your children and maybe you don't like
your children because you let them behave in ways that makes you not like them.
And so the way you take revenge is by not correcting them so that other people
will punish them because you don't have the courage to discipline them.
And if you think that people don't play that game,
then you don't know much about people because they play that game all the time.
All right?
So
it matters how you play the game.
It doesn't matter whether you win or lose.
Let's take that apart.
Well,
so the first thing is,
and this goes back to the idea of the hierarchy is order a hierarchy and the
answer is no,
it's a set of all hierarchies.
Or You could say it's the,
it's the set of all possible hierarchies because you know in,
in a society at a given time,
there's hierarchies that function.
But that transforms.
And then there's new hierarchies that function.
The specifics of the hierarchies change,
but the fact of the hierarchies remains.
And so you can imagine a hierarchy as a metal structure that consists of a
multitude of possible hierarchies.
And that's going to change as life continues.
And so what you want for your children is not to be the master of hierarchy you
want for your children to be the master of the set of all possible hierarchies,
because then no matter how things change,
they're ready say,
well,
how is it that you get ready for things to change?
And the answer is play so that people will invite you to play.
Right?
And there's a rule for,
for,
for children,
for raising children,
and it really,
it's a rule.
One of the things you can do with your children.
This is something good for men because men are more likely to do this than
women.
Although women can do it too,
but men are more likely to do it.
It's good for children to engage in rough and tumble play,
play fighting.
First of all,
if you have children and you've played with them physically,
you know that they absolutely love it.
They will rough and tumble play with you until you are completely exhausted and
they're not even vaguely ready to quit.
They have an inexhaustible hunger for it and they like it.
They like to be pushed to the edge.
So I knew this when I was a new father,
partly because I read work by a man named Jaak Panksepp,
who was a genius,
an effect of neuroscientists,
one of the world's great neuroscientists,
perhaps the world's greatest neuroscientists,
although there's four or five people that might compete with him.
He wrote a book called affective neuroscience,
emotional neural science,
which is a work of real genius.
He discovered the play circuit in mammals because there's a separate place
circuit in mammals,
a specialized circuit,
and he did a lot of work on rats and showing that in order for a rat to become
socialized because rats are highly social,
they had to engage in iterative bouts of rough and tumble play.
And here's a cool thing.
It's a ridiculously cool thing.
So,
and this has to do in some sense with the postmodern critique of the patriarchal
tyranny.
So if you take two juvenile rats,
males,
and
you imagine you give them an opportunity to play.
So you throw two of them into a little player in and you let them wrestle,
okay?
The next time that you bring them to the same place,
you can measure how much work they'll do to open the door to the arena,
how many times they'll push a button,
say to open the door or how hard,
how hard they'll pull if you tie a string spring to their tail and so you can
get an estimate of their motivation because the more motivated they are to play
at,
the harder they'll work and rats will work really hard to play so you know that
they want to play.
I mean assuming that you're willing to accept the fact that if you work for
something,
you want it.
It's like an operational definition,
so rats will work to play.
Now if you let the rats out in the play arena and one rat is 10 percent bigger
than the other,
then that rat will win.
You might say,
well,
what does winning mean?
Rats wrestle like people wrestle.
They even pin each other and they manifest play behavior to begin with,
like dogs playing in a park.
You know how a dog looks when it wants to play.
Sort of hunkers down a little bit.
It looks up at you like expectancy expectedly kind of moved back and forth,
which is like,
okay human,
I'm ready to play and if you have any sense and you know how to play,
then you look at the dog and you sort of go like this and the dog goes like this
and you cuff the dog not too hard and the dog bites you not too hard and then
you can play and you're both happy with that.
And kids can do that with dogs because kids understand dogs and dogs and kids
knew how to play.
If if your dog can play,
then you should not own a dog.
You're not smart enough to own a dog.
So it's true.
And if you have a dog that can't play,
then don't have a kid.
Right?
It's true.
Stupidest dog I ever saw was owned by a psychologist that was really
embarrassing.
So okay,
so you put the rat to rats together and there's the 10 percent bigger route and
there's the 10 percent smaller rat and the 10 percent bigger rat stomps the
small rat and pins him.
So he went.
And so now you're a postmodernist doing the experiment and you say powerful,
tyrannical rat dominates hierarchy.
Really?
That's what you conclude and to experiment and you're.
And it looks correct because powerful,
dominant rat dominated and one,
it's like,
okay,
cep,
for one thing,
rats live with rats.
No wonder they're not psychopathic individuals wandering from isolated community
die slated community.
They know all the other rats and that means they have to keep playing with them.
And the rules for playing with someone 30 times are not the same as the rules
for playing with someone once.
So Pang sap had the rats play repeatedly and what he observed was,
okay,
now the next time you put those rats together,
the situation's a little different.
The little rat comes bouncing out and does the playful dog thing too.
The big rat.
So now the rule is you're the little rat you lost.
You have to be the creature that invites to play.
That's now your status.
So you bounced around and you know the big rats all cool.
And he's smoking a cigarette and doesn't want to,
doesn't want to play,
but they'll flick it away at some point and think,
all right,
what the hell you know?
And so then he gets in it and so neat can stomp the little route again because
he's a bigger rat.
If the big Grad doesn't let the little rat win 30 percent of the time across
repeated play boats,
then the little rat won't ask him to play anymore.
You think,
well,
if you think about you don't think so what?
You don't think.
Why did Jaak Panksepp waste his time studying play in rats?
You Think,
oh my God,
that's an absolute miracle.
Because it shows you that there's an ethic of fairplay that emerges as a
consequence of repeated bouts of play.
Even among rats.
It's so basic.
It isn't even human.
That ethic,
they ethic of fairplay is deeper than human.
It's real.
And it's the ethic that governs iterated interactions.
And it's not just in rats that we've seen this.
So you know,
chimpanzees are pretty damn brutal.
They're way more brutal than you think.
And they're really,
really strong.
Maybe six times as strong as an adult male.
Now there's the estimates vary,
but there are plenty strong enough to tear you to bits and that happens now and
then people have chimps for pets and they become adults and it's like don't mess
with the chimp because it'll tear you to pieces and so and chimps are brutal and
this is interesting because they're our closest relatives and so Jane Goodall
discovered in the 19 seventies that rats or tribe or chimps are tribal.
They live in tribal groups like we do and they have a territory that's the known
territory and there's a perimeter that's the unknown.
That's chaos and other chimpanzees inhabit the chaos.
Foreign Chimpanzees and the juvenile chimps patrol the perimeters in groups of
four or five,
and if they spy us,
a foreign chimp or two of them,
if they outnumber them because they can't count,
but they have a sense of quantity.
If five chimps come across to foreign chimps,
they will tear them to bits and I actually mean that literally.
That's what they do and chimps also hunt.
They hunt colobus monkeys and they weigh about 40 pounds and they're quite
carnivorous and they will eat them alive.
Well,
they're screaming,
so there isn't a lot of empathy regulating chimp aggression,
which is something to think about when you think about human beings because it's
not obvious what regulates our aggression and you might think,
well,
it's your conscience and like,
yeah,
maybe it's your conscience and maybe it's something else.
You read the book,
have you read the rape of Nanking for example,
and you'll start wondering very,
very rapidly about whether people have any conscience at all.
So that's a story of absolutely atrocious Japanese behavior in China at,
at the beginning of World War II and it's a horrifying book.
So read it with caution,
but it's very instructive.
So anyways,
the chimps,
the chimps are very brutal creatures and so you might think,
well,
let's look at a chimp hierarchy because chimps have dominance hierarchies in
there.
Basically male dominated,
although there are lots of powerful female chimps say,
okay,
who becomes the dominant chimp?
And the answer might be,
and this would be the postmodern answer,
the most powerful tyrannical brutal chimp rules because it's power that moves
you up the hierarchy.
It's like that happened sometimes among chimps,
but you know what happens to tyron chimps,
they have an off day and to subordinate chimps each three quarters,
the size gang up to make a one and a half super chimp and then they tear him to
pieces.
Right?
So here's the rule.
If you're a chimp tyrants meet bloody ends.
So how do you conduct yourself as a chimp if you want to be at the top of the
hierarchy and have preferential access to the things that being at the top of
the hierarchy would give you and answer is engage in mutually reciprocal
interactions with your peers.
The chimps that rise to the top,
that stay there stable and also have the most stable functioning by the way,
are the ones that have friends that are long term and permanent and engage in
reciprocal interactions not only with their friends,
but also with the females and the infants.
And so even among chimps,
patriarchal tyranny,
a is not the norm and B is not the proper motive approaching the situation,
and so that speaks to a broader ethic.
The same kind of ethic that is spoken to with regards to the rat studies have
play behavior and you can see this sort of thing throughout the animal kingdom.
There's A.
There's a pattern of reciprocal interaction that seems to stabilize social
animals that isn't predicated on brute force.
Now maybe the simpler the animal,
the more it's predicated on brute force,
but we are by no means simple animals and the idea that our hierarchies are
fundamentally tyrannical.
The patriarchy,
which is a word that nobody who thinks carefully should ever use casually.
That term is predicated on the idea that a,
that are hierarchies are tyrannical,
which they aren't.
Although they can become that way and be that the most reliable means to
attaining status within a hierarchy is through the expression of power and both
of those things are wrong.
They're wrong.
And nonetheless,
that's the primary theory of the social sciences and the humanities,
and enough of that,
we've,
we have enough data to indicate that none of that's sufficiently sophisticated
to constitute a reasonable explanation of the world.
So we should dispense with it as fast as possible.
All it's doing is dividing us into tribes and it's not solving the problems that
it's hypothetically intended to solve.
So,
okay,
so now back to the question.
So
there isn't that hierarchy.
There's a set of hierarchies and it's like the set of games.
So here's what you're telling your child when you say it doesn't matter whether
you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
What you're telling them is life is not a game.
It's not even a sequence of the same games.
It's multiple sequences of different games.
And if you want to be a successful player in the set of multiple sequence of
different games,
then you have to adopt a higher order ethic.
And you don't subordinate that ethic to victory in any one game ever.
So you put the manner in which you play above your victory in,
in each instance.
And the reason that that produces the best possible outcome for you is that you
get invited to play the largest number of games.
And so let's go back to rule five.
Don't let your children do anything that makes you dislike them.
Okay?
So let's say you like your.
Let's say you love your children and you want the best for them.
You detach yourself and a little bit and you think,
well,
I'm not going to be around forever.
And they're going to deal with a lot of different people,
single people,
like individuals,
groups of people,
children and adults.
And what they have to be prepared for is to interact with that set of people in
the best possible manner.
Because.
And so what do you want?
Well,
let's say your child's two,
and it's still pretty egocentric because children two year olds are quite
egocentric.
They can't share yet.
They don't really learn how to share in any technical sense till were about
three.
It's hard for them to learn to share
between two and four.
They learn to share and to play.
And the way they learn is by at least in part,
by engaging in reciprocal interactions with their parents.
Now,
what is it that it.
What is it?
That's your job when you're socializing a child who's two to four,
you have to do it between the ages of two and four by the way,
because if you don't manage it by the time they're four,
then you might as well give up because it isn't going to happen.
And the literature on antisocial behavior in children is crystal clear on this
point.
If your child's antisocial at for you failed.
And there isn't anything that can be done about it.
It's a dismal literature.
And believe me,
psychologists and sociologists and anthropologists and criminologists have tried
for like six decades to figure out how to remediate antisocial behavior in older
children and adolescents and they haven't managed it.
So.
So two between two and four is crucial.
You want to help your child become the sort of person that other children want
to play with.
And the reason you want to do that is because from four onward,
other children are the primary agents of socialization.
And so if your children are accepted by other children,
then they're on their way because other children will socialize them.
It doesn't mean you're not important as a parent,
but it means they find their peers who are at the same developmental level as
them and they start to reciprocally socialize one another and they do that
through play.
And so if you've prepared your child to be a great play companion,
then you can just stand back and let it happen.
And you have to be around when something breaks down.
When the system doesn't work properly,
you have to be there as a resource.
But basically you can sort of push them out onto the playground and say,
you know,
you know what to do.
Go play and play is of absolutely crucial importance as documented by people
like John Piaget.
So you're trying to make your child maximally attractive as a play partner.
And the ethic there is while the world is made out of a sequence of hierarchies
that transform.
And so you want your child to be the sort of person who's invited.
Participate in what ever hierarchy organizes itself and how and what should a
child be like to do that while they have to be.
Be Reciprocal.
Take turns right.
You don't always get to pick the game.
You have to find out what other people want to do.
They have to want to play too.
Like there's all these sophisticated ethical rules that go around play and you
know if you're playing with some of you have played with kids that aren't fun to
play with,
well what do they like?
If something doesn't go their way,
what happens?
They have an emotional outburst so they revert to the behavior of a ill prepared
two year old.
They have a temper tantrum.
They burst into tears.
They thrashed around on the floor.
It's not fun because when you play,
if you don't lose some times that no one else ever wins,
so who the hell is going to play with someone like that?
A downtrodden victim,
that's all.
It's not.
No kid with any sense is going to put up with that.
All they do,
and this is exactly what kids are like,
if they find out that their potential play partner is a whiny two year old,
even though therefore they just start playing and they go find another kid,
that's exactly what happens,
and so if you want that for your kid,
then make sure that they're whiny and bitter every time they lose.
A good way to do that is to never let them lose at anything so they don't get
any practice.
Well,
I don't want my kid to lose.
It's wrong.
You don't want to.
You don't want your kid to lose in an unsophisticated manner.
That's not the same thing at all.
And if you think the way you accomplish that is by never having your kid lose,
then well then,
well then we're back to the.
You shouldn't even own a dog problem.
All right,
so then you might take apart.
What does it mean to be a desirable play partner?
Assuming you're gonna play reciprocal,
repeated games across all sorts of different contexts.
Well,
there's a,
there's a whole aspect that emerges from that.
See Nature back in the late 18 hundreds.
He was the first person to kind of caught onto this sort of thing because until
then,
people tended to think of morality as something that was invented rationally and
then imposed from the top down,
but nature being a very intelligent observer noted that well,
that wasn't really the case.
There was a ethic already built into human interactions that we all acted out,
but that we didn't really understand very well.
So here's a way to think about that.
So imagine you're watching a wolf pack and wolves compete for dominance.
And so the way they do that is they basically have a play fight about it.
Now it's this fairly serious play fight.
And so two wolves that are engaged in a dominance dispute will sort of sand
sideways to each other.
You know how cats do that?
Do you ever watched two caps fight cats stand sideways,
think,
well,
why does it cat stand sideways when it's fighting?
It's because a sideways cat is a bigger cat than a hand on cat.
So the cat's trying to intimidate the other cat so it stand sideways and it
puffs itself up including its tail.
And the reason it does that is so that it looks bigger because one cat isn't.
Cats don't want to fight,
they want to threaten until one cat backs down.
And so they puff themselves up and they make horrible noises and they face off
against each other,
but they don't want to fight because the two cats that are fighting my damage
each other,
then a third cat comes in and like wins.
It's a stupid strategy.
So it's,
it is.
It's so.
Most animals don't like to fight because they might damage to themselves.
And then another interloper.
We'll just,
when it's a stupid strategy and human beings are quite a bit like that.
We do a lot of posturing and defensive display,
an aggressive display and all that.
But we don't fight very often for the,
for the same reasons.
And it's only when those other mechanisms breakdown that we actually fight.
So
what happens in a wolf dispute is this,
the wolves square off and they amp up the threats in the hope that one of the
wolves will back the hell down.
Because what'll happen is the wolf will chicken out one of them.
And then when it does,
it rolls over and shows its neck.
Why?
Well,
because when wolves hunt,
they go for the neck generally,
like wolves are quite cruel creatures in some sense.
And they'll actually eat moose standing up.
But generally speaking,
if they can manage it,
they go for the throat and they'll bring the animal down.
And so what the wolf is basically saying is,
well you scared me half to death.
I'm a useful move.
I'm a useless moose.
You might as well tear up my neck.
And other wolf says,
yeah,
you're pretty detestable and you're kind of like a moose,
but I might need you to hunt tomorrow so I know I can tear out your neck,
but I won't.
And then the defeated Wolf stands up and he's not very happy and he's kind of a
low status wolf,
but at least he's still got his neck.
And the victor wolf gets to be high status wolf and he gets to go hunting with
his partner the next day.
And so you might think,
well,
wolves have a complex procedural morality and morality is don't tear the neck
out of your,
out of the out of the creature you defeat that's wrong.
And then you might say,
well,
that's the rule that will follow,
but that's wrong because wolves don't follow rules because wolves don't have
rules because they don't have language and they don't think not like us.
They act like they have rules.
They act so that if you watch them act,
you could label what they're doing with the rule.
That's how we got our rules.
We acted out and ethic and then we.
And then we coded it in stories.
That's what our religious stories are there.
The consequence of us watching what it is that we do when we act ethically and
then transforming that into a story and everyone's intent on that story exists
absolutely intent on the story of good versus evil,
let's say,
because that's the fundamental story.
And why do you want to watch that story?
Because you want to know how to be the victor in the set of all possible games.
And that's what that story's about and that's what movies are about.
And that's what books are about,
announced what religious narratives are about.
That's what everything that grips us at a literary level is about.
And the reason that it grips this is because that's what the world is made of
and that's what we need to know.
So then you might think.
So here's something to think about.
I'll give you a symbolic representation of this.
Okay?
So there's this idea in Christianity,
and I'm not talking about this from a religious perspective,
okay,
I'm talking about this from an anthropological perspective or a biological
perspective or a
that'll do an anthropological or a bylaw or psychological perspective.
So there's this idea in Christianity that Christ is Christ is the king of kings.
Okay?
So I'm going to take that apart.
So imagine that you have a hierarchy,
whatever it is,
and there's someone at the top of it.
And so that person has the attributes necessary to be at the top of that
hierarchy.
And maybe it's a hockey team and you go home and you tell a story about how the
best hockey player on your team played while they were being the best hockey
player.
It's a little hero narrative,
so little fragment of a hero narrative and maybe it's hockey,
soccer,
plumbing,
law,
business,
art.
There's all these hierarchies.
And then there's the thing that's at the top of all of them.
And the thing that's all the at the top of all of them has something in common.
That's whatever it is that's in common across all the things that are at the
top.
So imagine this,
okay,
so you could think about this.
Imagine that you're a novelist and you want to distill some characters and you
want the good evil character because what the hell good is your book without a
good evil character and you want a good,
good character because the same problem applies.
You don't want to just tell a story about some guy's Day,
right?
You don't want to say,
well,
John woke up at six and then he smacked his lips four times in blank 20 times
and then he swung his feet over across the bed and walked into the bathroom.
Because who cares about any of that?
You don't need to know that because you know how to move your mouth and cough
and walk to the bathroom.
It's not helpful.
You want to distillation.
You want the novelist who have watched a bunch of people and abstracted out
someone who's good in a way that's good across a bunch of people and you want
him to have abstracted out someone who's evil that's abstracted across a bunch
of evil characters,
so you see that in hamlet for example.
You see that Dostoevsky where the where the characters are bigger than life and
you want them bigger than life because you want it distilled so that you can
learn from it and what you're learning is that ethic.
Okay,
so that imagine that you have 100 hierarchies,
just mundane hierarchies.
Then you take the people at the top of all those hierarchies and say that you
group them into groups of 10.
Okay,
so you take 10 admirable people and then you say,
well,
we're going to average across them and we're going to come out with the most ad
with a compass it admirable person made.
Out of those 10,
you have 100 to begin with.
So let's say you have a thousand to begin with.
You distill them to 100 admirable people.
Then you take that hundred admirable people in,
you distill them into 10.
Then you take those 10 admirable people and you distill them into one and what
that one is is what's admirable across the entire set of admirable people.
That's a divine figure in a mythological story.
That's what it is.
And so the Christian ideas,
Christ is the king of kings and that's what it means.
You go into a cathedral and the cathedral is across by the way,
and the cross is the place where suffering is accepted and the cross is a dome
over it.
Then that's the sky.
Okay?
So there's an idea in the cathedral and the idea is that the place of the cross,
which is where suffering occurs,
is the center of the universe,
which is the Dome,
and then you look up at the Dome and you see this figure staring down at you.
That's the king of kings and that's how to behave in the world.
That's what that image represents.
And you think,
well,
what does it mean?
Well,
here's a way of unpacking it and this is associated with its associated with the
idea of how to behave across the set of all possible hierarchies.
Well,
what should you do?
according to rule one,
you should stand up straight with your shoulders back.
Okay?
Now the people who have been,
some of the people who've been criticizing me say,
well,
because I pointed out that hierarchies exist.
I'm justifying them.
It's like pointing out that something exists is not the same as justifying it.
It's just pointing out that it exists and pointing out that it exists without
justifying.
It is certainly not saying that the way to attain dominance in a hierarchy is
through power.
Was the other thing that I've been criticized for,
which is not what I'm saying.
In fact,
I'm not saying that.
No,
I'm not even saying that a little bit.
It's exactly the opposite of what I'm saying.
Say,
well,
what if you stand up straight with your shoulders back?
Isn't that a powerful stance?
And the answer is,
well,
actually no.
A powerful stance is this,
right?
Well,
not really because I'm not very good at it,
but if I knew what I was doing,
this would be it and I put myself sideways so I'm not much of a target and I'm
ready for attack.
Okay,
that's not this dance.
This dance is different.
Right,
and that that isn't this dance either.
This is a defensive crouch.
This is what happens if you're depressed and anxious,
right?
This dance is,
I'm willing to take what the world throws at me.
Right in.
That might be the trials and tribulations that are associated with the hierarchy
because that's a tough battle in and of itself,
but it also might be all the terrible unknown things that are going to come your
way.
What's the right attitude is stand the hell up with some courage and take it
right voluntarily with courage,
so it's actually a stance of maximal vulnerability,
vulnerability adopted voluntarily.
That's what the crucifix represents.
Just so you know,
it represents the willingness to take on the suffering of the world voluntarily,
the whole thing,
and that's associated with whatever at the top of the hierarchy.
So the idea is the best possible strategy that you have to be successful across
the set of all possible hierarchies is to maximally accept the fact that your
vote,
that you're vulnerable to accept that as the price of being,
and that's the essential message.
It's not only the message of Christianity by the way you see this sort of idea
expressed in all sorts of religious structures in the daoists to return to them
say,
well,
where should you be in the world?
The world is made out of the catastrophe of chaos and the tyranny of order.
Where do you stand in that place?
And the answer is with one foot in chaos and one foot in order.
That's the line down the middle.
That's the Tao.
That's the way,
that's the point of meaning.
It's the same place that's at the center of a cathedral.
It's the same idea.
You stand there because you're secure because you have tradition and the power
of your civilization behind you and you have one foot in chaos because that's
not enough and never will be,
and the instinct that puts you there is the instinct of meaning and you can use
that as a guide and it's a deep neurological instinct.
It's not some EPA phenomena.
It's the most real thing there is as far as I can tell and associated with that
as a certain attitude towards life,
which is to venture courageously out into the unknown,
is to put yourself on the line,
right,
to heed the call of adventure,
to risk yourself voluntarily.
You have no choice anyways,
right?
Because you're in this all the way.
There's no out that isn't death.
The full catastrophe is at your feet.
You can't evade or escape that,
but what you can do is choose how it is that you're going to confront it,
and so rule one is to stand up straight with your shoulders back and to
manifest,
and this is the thing that's so amazing about this,
I think,
and that what lands are kind of ultimate reality to the idea of positioning
yourself properly.
You might say,
well,
let's presume that you're a very pessimistic person or a very realistic person,
and you say,
well,
what's the fundamental reality of life?
You say,
well,
it's suffering and malevolence.
It's like,
okay,
it's a hard argument to forestall,
but I don't think it's true.
It's true,
but it's not.
It's not the final truth.
The final truth is,
despite the fact that that's true,
the ability of the human spirit to prevail is more powerful than death and evil.
That's the truth,
and you know that you know that,
first of all,
you know that because you're ashamed that you're not everything you could be.
You know that because the people that you admire are people who manifest courage
in the diarist of straights and you know that as well because when you meet
people like that and you're not like that,
they shame you.
That speaks to your deepest possible instinct.
You know what you could be and you know too that you see people contend with
situations that are so difficult that it's truly a miracle that they can contend
with them.
You know,
when I think of people,
well,
I think the people who work in funeral homes,
that's a good example.
That's hard,
right?
That's death and grief every day and it's not something that you can avoid.
It's like it's right there.
It's as real as it can possibly be.
I'll tell you a story about that.
Had a client who was very afraid of being alive and she wanted to sleep all the
time and she took sleeping pills and all sorts of other things so that she could
evade the burden of being conscious and she was a very good dreamer and she.
She wasn't doing well in university and she had a dream one night that
Gypsy told her that she was actually lucid during her dreams by the way,
and she could ask her dream characters what they meant and they would tell her,
which was something I'd never seen anyone else manage.
In any case,
she jumped up this gypsy that she met in the forest and the Gypsy told her that
unless she learned to,
unless she could learn to work in a slaughter house,
she never finished her degree and so she told me that story.
I don't know if you know this,
but the classic treatment for people who are afraid of things is to expose them
to what they're afraid of.
Which is a good lesson if you have children because you want to expose your
children to challenges because that makes them stronger.
It has to be done voluntarily,
but if you have posttraumatic stress disorder,
let's say you're the of a vicious sexual assault by a stranger and two years
later you have posttraumatic stress disorder.
The most effective treatment is to get you to relive the experience in as much
vivid detail as you possibly can and experience all the emotions that occurred
while it was happening and if the.
If you do that,
the more upset you get when you do that,
if you do it voluntarily,
the faster you get better and the longer you stay better,
and so it's a general rule of thumb in psychotherapy is if someone's avoiding
something,
find out what they're avoiding,
break it into manageable pieces and have them voluntarily expose themselves to
it and they will be cured.
And that's the dragon fight in,
in clinical practice,
find what you most want to what you most need will be found where you least want
to look right.
That's a hell of a statement.
So she told me this dream and I thought,
well,
I don't know how to arrange for you to work in a slaughter house.
That doesn't seem like very.
She wouldn't eat meat by the way.
She wouldn't go into a butcher store.
I took her into a butcher store once and she had a very catastrophic reaction.
She couldn't handle it anyways.
I said,
well,
we can arrange the slaughterhouse thing.
Why don't you go away and for a while and come back in a week and see if you can
come up with an alternative.
So,
uh,
she came back and she said,
I want to see an embalming.
And I thought,
Oh God,
okay,
how the hell am I going to arrange that?
So I phoned a couple of funeral homes and I said,
look,
I've got this person who's really afraid of death and she had this dream and I
told them the story and they said,
no problem,
bring her in.
And so I wasn't looking forward to this by the way.
Um,
so we went and she was very,
very nervous because she certainly didn't think she could handle that.
And as I said already,
I wasn't exactly thrilled about it either,
but in,
for a pound in,
for a penny in,
for a pound as they say.
So anyways,
we went to the funeral parlor and they showed us around and we asked a bunch of
questions like,
how the hell did they cope with their jobs?
Because that's just a mystery to me.
And they said,
well,
it was actually really useful for them to guide people through the process of
grief and that their experience was that that had given them a renewed
appreciation for life,
which is well
that would account for why they were able to do it because it seems like a very
hard job.
And so we went into this room and watch this embalming and I was about eight
feet away from this small room.
It's a pretty gruesome operation as you might imagine.
And uh,
my client was sitting beside me and I was watching her and watching the
embalming as well.
And for the first while she was just looking to the side,
which was,
I'm not here and I certainly can't handle that and no bloody wonder literally.
And so.
But then she would take the odd glance,
say she'd go like this and then look away.
And then as the minutes by,
but fairly rapidly,
she was spending more time watching and less time looking away until she was
finally doing nothing but watching.
And then at some point she asked if she could come in and put her hand on the
body,
and so they gave her a glove and she did that and then she went and sat down and
she was quite quiet about all this and quite quiet afterwards as well.
So what did she discover?
Well,
she didn't discover the death was,
wasn't horrible.
She didn't discover that and she didn't discover the death wasn't terrifying
because it certainly was.
But what she did discover was that she was a hell of a lot tougher than she
thought,
and,
and much quicker than she would have believed.
And she went away thinking,
Huh,
look at that.
I did the thing I was most afraid of doing.
And here I am.
Not only am I not more damaged than I was,
I'm actually better than I was.
And so from then on she had a reference point.
Right?
Which is an interesting thing.
I think this is why primordial people initiate their,
especially their young men,
because it sort of happens automatically with young women.
They expose their young men to something absolutely terrifying,
genuinely terrifying.
So for the rest of their lives,
they know the difference between what's actually terrifying and what's just sort
of normal catastrophe because you really need to know that,
right?
Because you need to know that you can prevail and one of the things she learned
as a consequence of that exposure was that she could prevail despite the
realities of life.
Of course,
that's what you want to teach your children mostly by example,
is that they can prevail despite the realities of life.
Of course,
that also means that you have to have admitted to what the realities of life
are.
But the thing that's so interesting about that.
Here's another story.
So you know the story of King Arthur and the holy grail.
The holy grail is the ultimate value that it's a symbol of whatever the ultimate
value is.
And King Arthur assembles is nights around the round table and it's a round
table because they're all equal.
Despite the fact that they have a king,
they sit as equals at the round table and they all decided to go off to seek for
the holy grail.
It's either the cup that Christ drank out of at the last supper,
the cup that held his blood on the cross.
It's one of those two things.
It doesn't really matter.
It's a symbol of what's redemptive.
That's what the holy grail is,
so it's a representation of the ultimate value.
The question is where do you go to seek out what's of ultimate value and answer
in,
in the tail of of King Arthur and the holy grail is that each night entered the
forest when they began their search at the place that looks darkest to them.
So that's the thing is that it's necessary if you're going to stand up straight
with your shoulders back to confront the darkness of the world,
head on,
to take responsibility for the tragedy of existence and for for malevolence.
That's what it means.
That's the what the Christian injunction to take the sins of the world onto
yourself means it means it's your bloody problem,
and to confront Satan in the desert is the same idea,
is that not only do you have to take on the tragedy of the world as if it's your
responsibility,
but you have to contend with the spirit of malevolence while you're doing so,
and it's in doing that,
that you find your destiny.
That's where you find the highest of possible values and that's the call and
that's the call to the nobility of being because you might think,
well,
what could possibly justify your life more thoroughly?
What could make you the best player of all possible games than to take the
tragedy of the world onto your shoulders and to fight with all your ability
against the malevolence in your own heart.
Thank you.
The first one I'll choose here.
Thank you for coming to speak with us.
What do you think of Iceland?
Well,
first of all,
thank you all for coming.
It's quite remarkable to see so many people come out for such a serious
conversation.
It isn't exactly what you'd expect.
So,
um,
everyone has been ridiculously hospitable to me and my family.
Um,
we've seen some beautiful things.
We were at the blue lagoon,
which was very impressive.
We went to the house today where Gorbachev and Reagan met in 1996 and that was
very interesting.
I went and saw some rare manuscripts at the university this morning,
a lager and his crew of people have been very organized and you have a beautiful
little capital city that's extraordinarily impressive and you've produced this
amazing venue and your country is cruising along on all cylinders and it's a
hell of an achievement.
So that's what I think.
I,
I think that almost all the time when I come to a European country,
it's amazing how well it works.
I mean,
it's a harsh place,
you know,
it's,
you made a lot of what you have and it looks to me like it's just getting better
and so it's peaceful and productive and civilized and beautiful and hospitable
and
good for you.
And thank you for inviting me.
I'm this one.
The next one is regarding the headpieces on you.
Um,
when such an article is written,
what is your interpretation of the costs or further potential explanations are
there for this phenomenon?
Well,
I think there's,
you know,
we could start with what I might be contributing to it
now.
One thing I've had to learn,
I've had some interactions with public exposure for probably
15 years because I worked a little bit with a public television station in
Ontario before all this blew up.
My producer who was someone who was very much on my side.
So I worked for a public affairs show first of all as irregular panelist and
then as a columnist for a couple of years.
My producer,
who is the level headed guy
well versed in what worked well in panel discussions,
told me to be very careful about controlling my proclivity towards anger because
it doesn't play very well publicly.
And so
no,
I kept trying to learn the doctrine of minimal necessary force.
I mean,
I think that aggression is a good thing if it's controlled.
I think it's a good antidote to fear.
I think it's one of the things that can help you maintain your ground in the
face of resistance,
but it has to be applied very,
very judiciously and it isn't obvious that I always do that as well as I might
end.
If you're going to deal with difficult and dangerous and contentious issues,
then you're going to get punished for your failures.
And so I'm trying to learn too
detach myself and to not,
not in a,
not in an I don't care way,
no,
but in a watchful way and to keep all of that under control as much as possible
and to use minimal necessary force and it's hard to learn to do that well.
And so to the degree that I don't do that,
then I instigate more opposition than I might.
Now I have a hard time with that to some degree because I do find some of what I
have been,
let's say opposing,
um,
what would you say
it,
it makes me deeply,
it disturbs me deeply and makes me unhappy and ashamed.
That's particularly the case when I see what's happening at the universities.
I'm not impressed by what's happening in the social sciences and the humanities.
I'm not impressed with the postmodernists.
I'm not impressed with the Marxists and I'm certainly not impressed with the
people or the theories that juxtapose the two in this particularly ideological
brew that's been fermenting say since the 19 sixties and so it's not easy to
maintain equanimity in the face of that,
but it doesn't matter because it's still necessary to.
Do you think their ideology has permeated all of media or because not all of it?
Yeah,
I mean that's the other thing is that,
and this is why dealing now,
now we can turn to what the media might bring to this.
Well,
ideological,
ideological pre commitments.
That's certainly the case and inability to see anything other than in
politicized terms.
Like I don't view that what I'm doing as fundamentally political.
Actually.
In fact I don't view the battle that's raging in the idiation substructure of
our society is fundamentally political.
I think it's deeper than political.
It's at least philosophical and it's probably theological,
but the but the people who've been pillaring me,
let's say who tend to be the postmodern neo marxists types,
or at least leading in that direction cannot conceptualize anything that isn't
political in their world.
There isn't anything that isn't political.
One of the things that you might consider,
for example,
is you know,
I've been perhaps represented as an as an advocate of free speech,
and of course there's a lot of debate about what free speech really is from the
radical leftist types and here's something that you have to understand from the
collectivist perspective that dominates the radical left.
There is no such thing as free speech.
It's not that they oppose it,
it's that it isn't a move in their game.
It doesn't exist.
So if you stand up and say,
I'm manifesting my opinion as an individual,
then that's not a acceptable move because you aren't an individual.
You're an Avatar of your dominant group and whatever you otter,
regardless of why you think you're honoring it or regardless of whether you
think it's your individual opinion is nothing but a power move in your dominance
hierarchy and so it's not like they oppose free speech.
It's that it doesn't exist in their conceptual framework and so that's one of
the things that drives and they hit pieces because I do believe in the
individual
and I do believe in free speech and I do believe in a world outside the
conceptual realm,
all sorts of propositions that aren't part and parcel of the postmodernist slash
neo Marxist game and they're not very happy with that.
I'm not playing by the rules and so they don't know what to do about that.
The simplest thing to do is to call me far right,
are all right because then they can.
First of all,
that's an evil category and that dispenses with that,
but it also means they don't have to contend with any of my arguments and that's
convenient,
so it's easier to demonize than it is to contend.
So it doesn't seem to help them because the more they scream,
the more people that actually listen to you hear that are not far right.
You're not all thrive.
And they stopped believing them.
Well,
that's the other thing.
I've talked with my wife about this because it's been in been.
It's produced a lot of tension in our family because it's very stressful.
I mean,
for all sorts of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them,
you know,
I mean,
it's certainly not the case that when I read a headpiece that I'm very pleased
about it and I'm often quite worried about it.
Like the New York Times piece,
for example,
is a good example and it's idiot.
Um,
what would you call it?
insistence that I was promoting,
you know,
monogamy with the weapons of the state of all the insane ideas.
I mean,
who the hell believes that it's like some isis guys.
That's about it.
So,
so it's an,
it's a completely absurd accusation and it certainly bore no resemblance to
anything that I meant.
But you know,
it's a powerful media organization and lots of people warned me in the immediate
aftermath of that,
that it would be my downfall and including people who were less,
they weren't fearful people.
And so it's very stressful.
So one question is,
well,
should I be doing interviews like that at all?
Because one of the things I thought is no written interviews only live
interviews,
only the whole thing.
So the one today you had is the last one.
Well see,
I don't know because the,
there's another side of it which is decide you laid out.
It's like this happened with the,
some of you have seen the channel for interview that I did with Kathy Newman.
Thank you.
You know when that was,
I would say that was a stressful interview and I would say that the two weeks
after the interview we're also very stressful because,
you know,
first of all there was the interview and I thought they just cut it to seven
minutes and pillory me and leave it at that.
But they it to seven minutes and pilloried me.
And then they posted the whole interview,
which just shocked me,
but here's the shocking thing.
The people who posted that interview thought it went well.
That's why they posted it.
They didn't think,
oh my God,
this is contentious.
We better put it out,
believe me.
They didn't think that that is not what they thought.
They thought it went fine.
And so then there was this overwhelming response to it and that was completely
unexpected.
And then the counter response was,
Peterson's army of alt right trolls is victimizing Kathy Newman.
And that was.
That was the response of her employers,
the technical response,
because that's what they publish.
They said we had to call the police to evaluate the threat.
It's like,
well,
so what anybody can call in police to evaluate a threat.
It doesn't mean that the threat justified police intervention or that there was
a threat.
It just meant that that's how you responded to it.
And then they spun the victim narrative for Kathy,
which was I think reprehensible.
Given that.
I don't know what Kathy Newman is exactly,
but she's not a bloody victim.
She's not powerless.
She's one of the most powerful women in the United Kingdom and she has a salary
that's commensurate with that and good,
good for her.
That's absolutely fine,
but you don't get to have that and also be a victim.
It's not the right way to play the game.
And so then a whole bunch of newspapers laid out the story that poor Kathy was
being trolled by my legion of all right,
angry people,
but then the numbers started to mount,
you know,
an after it was like 4 million people.
It got the whole troll argument got hard to sustain unless you think there are
like,
well now it's perhaps 30 million people have watched either the whole thing or
major clips from it.
Maybe it's more than that.
It's hard to sustain the old troll argument when it's 30 million people,
but it was very.
I thought that narrative was going to prevail for a while that you know,
oh,
she got victimized and it was all these terrible people that went after her.
But that collapsed.
But it's very stressful.
But,
and this is something that I've,
I've learned,
so I've been obsessing about another statement in the New Testament for about
two years.
I've been trying to figure it out,
and it's,
it's the statement that you should turn the other cheek and that's a tough one,
man,
because.
Well,
because first of all,
who wants to do that?
Because you want to explode in righteous anger.
At least you want to defend yourself.
You want to do one of those things.
So what the hell does that mean?
And partly what it means is
if you're attack
and you're innocent,
and and look,
I'm not saying I'm like globally innocent or anything like that,
but I'm not guilty of the accusations that are levied at me or at least I not
guilty in the manner that the accusations would indicate.
If you're being attacked and you're not guilty of the accusations,
then the attacks
say more about the attacker then their intended target.
And so,
so far I've been able to withstand the attacks.
And the consequence of that is that it said more about the attackers then about
meat.
And then the question is,
can I tolerate that because it's still very stressful and
I very a waiver on that back and forth.
And then of course the other issue is is that some people in the media of
pilloried me,
but many haven't.
You know,
there've been very many thoughtful people that have written thoughtful pieces
about me.
There's a Canadian consortium of 200 newspapers,
the post media group,
and they came out.
The entire group came out in favor of my stance in relationship to bill
[inaudible] in Canada,
which was a speech,
a speech piece of legislation that compelled speech and so
well,
so,
so far,
same with the protests.
When people come out to protest against me.
The first video that went viral was a protest at the University of Toronto and
after the protest was over that the pro,
the anti free speech,
people at the protests took the microphone away in and blasted white noise and
made it impossible for anyone to speak even though it was an open mic event.
So that got broadcast and then about two hours after the event I went down to
talk to the cops.
To see if anybody had been hurt or anything like that,
and then on the way back into the university,
I go to Costco and buy half a dozen like radical types and about 30 of their
hangers on and then there's a crowd of people that I would say we're probably
supporting me that that gathered around me and they went after me and videotaped
all of it on their cell phones and then they posted that and the idea was that
that was going to do me in,
but what happened was the comments were a 100 to one in favor of what I was say.
So that was another example where the protests were more damaging to the
protestors then they were to me,
and that's been luckily fortunately,
miraculously all of that,
a recurrent pattern.
And so the question is whether or not I can tolerate it and whether my family
can tolerate it.
And so far,
look,
if you're trying to do something difficult,
let's say the right amount of controversy isn't zero.
The question is how much controversy can you handle and how much of the mud
that's thrown will stick.
And then how much of it deserves to stick all of those things.
You go to scour your conscience under those circumstances.
But
so I've been fortunate.
It seems like you've taken on this dragon voluntarily.
It seems like from the beginning you've known that this,
for example,
when you
spoke up against a biddle see 16 in Canada,
you knew that this might become tough.
Well Guide taught people to negotiate in my clinical practice for a long time.
You know,
I've had lots of clients,
many of those clients were female and the are the goal in my consulting with
them was to double or triple their salary within five years.
And so that wasn't necessarily the only goal.
We discussed all sorts of goals,
but that was often one.
And so I was very accustomed to organizing people to negotiate and there's,
if you want to negotiate,
there's a couple of rules.
The first rule is you have to be able to say no.
And what no means is there isn't anything you can do to me to get me to do that.
That's what no means.
Now,
like you can be.
You can have different degrees of seriousness about no,
but if you're going to negotiate with your boss,
say for a substantial raise,
no means if I don't get it,
then I will leave.
That's fundamentally and leaving will cost you more than.
It's not a threat,
right?
It has to be the observation that me leaving will cost you substantially more
than giving me the rates.
You have to be in a position to make that case or you don't win the negotiation.
And so I always put my clients in a position where if they went and asked for
something,
they were in a position to win because we didn't go and ask before that.
So when I made the video criticizing bill c 16,
I thought I'm not abiding by this damn piece of legislation.
And then I thought,
well,
what does it mean that I'm not?
And I thought,
well,
I had multiple sources of income.
So I was reading.
I was reasonably positioned to tolerate a fair bit of push back.
I mean,
I could've gotten wiped out.
You had things gone sideways,
but it would have been difficult to take me out completely and I thought
there's no way I'm abiding by this piece of legislation.
I was willing,
I thought through the negative consequences now I didn't of course think that
any of this would happen because this is just completely preposterous and no one
could have possibly foreseen it,
but.
So I would say there were certain things I faced in doing that,
but I couldn't have foreseen the absolutely explosive consequences.
I'm not unhappy that I did it.
I would do it again.
I am still doing it.
I suppose.
So,
um,
which of your 12 rules do you break most often?
I could probably still be better at listening to people I like.
I have these,
um,
I do interviews with people.
I call them discussions because they're not really interviews.
Probably they're not interviews because I talked too much,
so I had to call them discussions.
But I would say the most common criticism of those discussions is that I'm in,
I interrupt the people that I'm discussing things with and until the
conversation probably a little bit more towards me,
my thinking then there is now part of that I think is my natural tendency
towards like I've always talked a lot ever since I was like three,
like
continually.
So it's,
I'm there,
I'm verbally fluent,
you know,
it's part of my nature and extroverted.
But
you can always get better at listening,
you know?
And so I can listen and,
and I practiced that because I'm a therapist.
But I would say that's probably the rule.
I break that rule nine,
like assume that the person you're listening to know something you don't.
It's like I'm not as good at that yet as I could be because I wouldn't get that
criticism if I was like,
it's not every comment or anything.
It's probably like every 20th comment or every 30th comment,
but it's.
But it's still,
it's consistent.
And so every time I have an interview I think,
okay,
I'm going to try to shut up a little bit more.
But then I get excited about what's happening and you know,
and talk too much.
One thing related to that,
sometimes you seem to go off on a tangent.
When you're discussing something,
you go into a,
you know,
something related to it,
then you come back to a greater structure of things.
Um,
do you have you laid all this out before you say it or do you just go from one
topic to another and they somehow relate together and become whole?
Um,
both.
Both.
Yeah.
But so before I do a talk,
like I have to,
I think about the talk all day before I do it,
like not 100 percent of the time,
but it's,
it's in my mind all the time and what I'm trying to get as the basic narrative
and it's something you can only use a metaphor to describe it.
So imagine you wanted to cross a swamp and there were stones under the surface.
You need to know where the stones are to get from one side of the swamp to the
other.
And so then that's what I do in my imagination,
I think,
okay,
well there's this area I have to traverse and there's stepping stones along the
way.
I need to know where they're located.
And so that might be like 12 points or something like that.
That's the rough path.
And then I have a whole corpus of stories that fit each of those points and then
I can choose how I'm going to weave those together.
But I have to remember where I'm going.
If I'm.
Well,
like if I'm healthy and functioning properly,
then I can go way out on a tangent and I can still remember,
Oh yes,
I have to tie that back to this point and move to the next step.
So it's,
I like,
I think it's like jazz improvisation essentially,
you know,
you have the melody and it,
it has to organize the melody has to organize all the improvisation.
And then I have all these stories that I know,
but I,
every time I tell this story I try to vary it so that it brings in something I
haven't brought in before.
Integrate something,
you know,
like what are the things I was trying to do tonight,
I've been trying to figure out for a long time is how to integrate the idea of
the good player of games with the idea of voluntarily shouldering you're the
catastrophe of life.
I know those are the same thing,
but it's not obvious why and I'm still not completely obvious to me,
but I know that the connection exists and I got a fair bit of fairways tonight
farther than I had at stacking those concepts on top of each other.
So the other thing I'm always trying to do is to take each of these sets of
ideas and to weave them together more tightly,
but also to push them further in their development.
So.
And you've been doing that on this tour.
Have you been developing your ideas?
Go.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
There's.
You can't give an effective lecture without.
So
you don't deliver a talk to an audience.
First of all,
it's not app talk second,
you don't deliver it.
Third,
it isn't an audience like all of that's wrong.
You talk to individuals in the audience one at a time and they're representative
of the whole,
but you're not talking to the audience.
If you're afraid of public speaking,
it's [inaudible].
You're talking to the audience.
It's like,
forget about that.
You just talked to people.
You know how to do that,
and then you're not delivering a talk because then it's a canned product.
You muscle just hand people pieces of paper that they could read.
It's more efficient.
Why not do that?
What you're doing if you address people properly is that you involve them in the
process of furthering exploration of important concepts and you think,
well,
how can you do that?
Because they're sitting there passively.
It's like,
well,
you're not passive.
You're not verbal,
but when you're not passive,
like I listened,
I listened to whether or not everyone's rustling around.
If you're rustling around,
then I'm not balancing chaos in order to properly.
You're not gripped.
If you're.
If I can hear noise in the audience,
it's not right.
I watched one by one and I see sometimes they're shaking their head like this.
Sometimes they're nodding.
Sometimes they look confused.
If if people look confused,
I think,
well,
I haven't got that right.
I have to be watching people and seeing that they're understanding,
they're following along and that indication that they're following along helps
me figure out if I'm in the right place,
and so there's a dynamic that goes along with it and so all of that,
and that's what you're doing if you engage the audience properly,
is you shouldn't be talking about things you don't know enough about to talk
about.
So if you have to read your notes,
it's like,
sorry,
you don't know enough to talk about that because you need notes.
Now.
Maybe when you're first starting to talk about something,
you need notes,
but if you need notes,
you haven't prepared enough.
You should know like 10 times as much about the topic.
Then you're going to talk about in the talk.
Otherwise,
who the hell are you?
And so while right,
I mean you're.
You're supposed to be the authority,
so you need to know these things and so and then knowing these things,
you want to stretch them further because when you're.
This is a theater and lecture theater.
Theater is drama,
so why is it a lecture?
Theater?
[inaudible] lecture is drama.
What's the drama?
Drama delivering a talk.
No,
there's no drama in that.
A tape recorder can do that.
The drama is to engage with the ideas actively in real time and to discover with
the audience what the consequences and that's what makes a novel great.
For example,
the reason that Dostoyevsky novel is great is because Dostoevsky did not know
where he was going when he started.
He had problems,
you know,
like crime and punishment is a great example.
He wanted to explore the relationship between crime and punishment.
He didn't think,
well,
I'm a postmodern,
neo marxists tonight.
I have a solution to the problem of crime and punishment and I'm going to write
a novel describing what the right solution is.
He thought,
here's a problem,
man.
This is a major problem.
I'm going to divide myself into 10 characters and I'm going to have a war and
I'm going to see what prevails,
and he takes you along on that voyage and it's.
That's what makes Dostoevsky different than Ayn rand.
For example,
because Ayn rand already knew who the good guys and the bad guys were and maybe
she was right and maybe she wasn't.
Doesn't matter what matters is that what she did wasn't literature.
It was just sophisticated propaganda,
you know,
like it,
it taps into literature upon occasion,
but,
but she knew where she was going.
Whereas Dusky Dostoevsky,
he discovered it along the way and so he takes you along on the journey and
that's any great artists does that takes you along in the journey.
That's why it's so rare vivifying to encounter anything that's genuinely
artistic is because you're along for the conflict between chaos and order and
that's way more interesting than having a talk delivered to you.
Is it possible that that journey might lead to a bad.
In some cases you've spoken of Hitler when he was speaking to audiences and he
was listening to the audiences and that and he started to find what really
engaged them and made them,
um,
yeah,
excited.
He was saying,
is it possible that you might get it wrong because of that dynamic?
Oh,
definitely.
And it's a terrible threat to get it wrong because you know,
in,
in rule three,
make friends with the people who want the best for you.
There are other rules that were associated with that that I didn't write about.
Like make friends with people with own.
No.
Let's see.
Be Very careful with who.
Be Very careful about who you share good news with.
That was one rule and another rule was be very careful about whom you share bad
news with.
And those are sort of hallmarks of friendship.
If you have friends,
you can tell good news too.
You know what it's like to tell good news to someone that you shouldn't tell.
Good news too.
It's like they're not happy about your good news.
There are bitter about it and they'll show it in some way.
Maybe they'll trump your good news or they won't listen.
Or they'll bring up another topic or they're secretly angry or whatever.
You walk away from sharing the good news thinking you should have kept your damn
mouth shut and that's not a good sign.
And then.
But some people you can tell good news too and they'll be happy because they
have enough sense to know that life's to catastrophe.
And if something good happened to you,
then hooray.
You know,
because and then bad news is the same thing.
It's like if you tell bad news to someone,
they need to let you suffer,
right?
They shouldn't make you feel better quick because they're upset because you're
upset,
none of that.
They just have to take it.
And that's hard.
So the,
I think I forgot what the hell the question was here.
I'm getting tired so I'm losing my ability to go back
where you may get it wrong when you're interacting with the audience.
Yes.
Look
what Hitler did was this far as I can tell,
and I've talked to politicians who've,
who've built grassroots political parties about how they did it too.
So
the audience talks to you when you,
when you deliver,
when you,
when you speak publicly and they talk to you with their emotional reactions,
and then you can learn how to say what produces a given emotional reaction,
especially if that's what you want.
If you want,
say,
control over the crowd or maybe you want,
you want to harness the anger of the crowd.
Let's say [inaudible] your own motivations.
What were Hitler's motivations?
Here's the psychoanalytic answer.
If you cannot understand the motivations,
look at the consequences and infer the motivation.
What's the consequence?
Hitler blows his brains out in a bunker under Berlin when Europe is on fire.
What was the motivation as suicidal apocalypse?
That's the motivation.
How do you generate as suicidal apocalypse?
You a mad it.
How do you get the crowd to go along?
You speak in that manner and you watch for the emotional response and when you
get the anger that you're after,
you facilitate it and you let your imagination dwell on that and you become a
master of that and that's what Hitler did and it wasn't like the Germans weren't
angry and they had their reasons.
World War One was brutal.
They lost the Versailles treaty was a catastrophe in the 19 twenties.
Every decent hardworking German lost all of their savings in hyperinflation and
the entire country was threatened by a radical leftist revolution.
It was rough and people were not happy and many of them had been terribly
brutalized by world war one,
so there was no shortage of anger to capitalize on and Hitler was just the guy
annoyed as he was,
for example,
that he was rejected from art school three times despite despite having a fair
bit of artistic talent.
He had his reasons for resentment and anger and hatred and that's just a tiny
part of it.
Yes.
These things can go terribly wrong.
It depends,
at least in part on what you're aiming at.
People ask me what I'm aiming at and I would say,
I mean who knows,
right?
Because you don't know yourself and I don't know myself not to the final depths,
but I think what I'm aiming at,
I'm hoping is exactly what I say I'm aiming at.
I hope that what I'm aiming at is to tell people stories
and provide them with clinical intervention in information that's derived from
the best literature and science that I know so that they can be fortified in
their ability to contend with tragedy and malevolence and the reason that I'm
doing that.
As far as I'm concerned is because when I wrote my first book,
which was maps of meaning,
the audio version of which is out next week,
by the way,
I think it'll be easier to understand because it's red and the intonation is all
there.
I concluded after studying the psychological dynamics of the Cold War,
that the only proper medication to tyrannical collectivism was the sovereignty
of the individual and that as a consequence,
the sovereign individual needed to be strengthened.
That that was the path forward was least harm and most potential good.
And I think that's what I'm doing my evidence for that is that I've been doing
it for 30 years.
I taught courses based on that at Harvard and at the University of Toronto
consistently.
The lectures were made into a television program in Toronto that was popular.
The lecturers became explosively popular online.
Everybody can see what I'm saying as far as I can tell and apart from the hip
pieces,
which are perhaps valid criticisms,
although I don't believe so.
Um,
the overwhelming evidence as far as I can tell is that it's having a positive
consequence.
So,
and I'm hoping,
and I have people watching me and criticizing me,
like friends of mine in my family,
trying to make sure that this all works and so hopefully
I'm not doing something that isn't good.
We'll see.
But yes.
Thanks.
The last,
last question,
what did you think of the last star wars movie?
I've gone,
I don't know if I saw the last star wars movie,
but I saw one of the last.
I've probably seen three of the last five star wars movies I would say,
and I thought they were all the same movie as the First Star Wars movie.
So,
um,
so I haven't,
they haven't been my cup of tea.
Let's say I'm having said that,
it's obvious that,
you know,
the superhero movies,
the star wars movies,
the star trek movies,
the fantastic success that marvel in particular has had with their Superhero
Pantheon.
Like those are the most expensive artifacts that people make a,
those movies.
That's something to really think about.
You know,
people put $200,000,000 into a movie like that.
It's not the most expensive thing we make,
but it's bloody well up there.
I can tell you,
and it's pretty interesting to realize as well,
but making the special effects for those movies which,
which is a form of artificial reality,
let's say,
is part of what's driving computational sophistication forward because the big
processors are being used most intensively to render reality.
And so whatever's happening in those movies is something far more significant
than you might think.
I think it all speaks to the unquenchable power of mythology and its proclivity
to manifest itself in a multitude of forms and,
and,
and to be in t eternally compelling to people.
And so generally that seems to be a really good thing to me.
So I mean the Harry Potter series I think is a better example than the star wars
series because I think that,
I think that the star wars series is a bit too consciously contrived.
Whereas the Harry Potter series is genuinely to my way of thinking anyways,
is it genuine intuitive production?
Um,
and rolling got her mythology.
She so good at that.
I just can't believe it.
It's just absolutely unbelievable.
And you think of the consequences of that.
She wrote seven books about wizards like teenage wizards and child wizards and
magical castle threatened by giant snakes and portrayed the battle between good
and evil on a landscape of chaos and order and sold.
I don't know what's her empire worth in terms of total financial consequences?
It would be.
It's in the tens of billions of dollars.
Certainly.
She got all these kids to read 600 page books.
They produced all these movies that were fantastically expensive.
Everybody read them and went and watched them.
It's like,
and what do you see there?
It's dying and resurrecting hero fights is satanic.
Figure and attains final victory through death and resurrection.
So like,
you know,
and it wasn't contrived that came out of the story.
And so
the mythologies seeps in no matter what.
And it's,
I think,
and this is something I learned from you,
is that it's time for us to understand it.
We can't just live by it unconsciously anymore.
We have to understand that as well as living by it.
And that's the task of the 21st century.
That's what it looks like to me.
So if we understand it,
then maybe we can fortify ourself against collectivist ideology,
for example.
I'm hoping because that's a bad pathway.
So you were able to turn that question into a very good final words somehow.
Good.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank
you.